out of 10,000 times that all the other people get embarrassed
way more than you do. That's the currency your universe runs
on is humiliating each other. I know Lav is extremely insecure
about Goon getting with Kimmy. I've always known Lab hated Kim
and was insecure. She would message Kim about how she's jealous
of her, etc. So, make sure to remind Lab on a daily basis that
she was the second option. It happened to you one time. You're
acting like it's the end of the world. Fire up the stream. Go
live. Run the end of the scavenger hunt. Collect your million
dollars you're going to make over the week and a half you're
doing this and stop pretending that you're a victim. That's
behavior. Okay, that's [__] made. Let We don't know.
I don't have any personal relationship with you. I'm just out
here grinding, bro. Can't hate on me. I Dude, you can't hate
on I'm just making content, okay? What the [__] We
don't have any personal relationship. I don't know you. I understand
it, but it's very hurtful. You know,
>> you have to start off with the Ice Poseidon logs, okay?
Now, I had to go and do this again where I had to go through
his Discord and actually go and get all the context for everything
and all of his posts throughout the day. Okay, cuz I love you
guys. So, I spent 30 minutes going in all of this stuff. 30 minutes.
Probably like 15 minutes, 20 minutes, but he's not turning down
that money. Yeah, I guess not. Connor wants to get paid, guys.
Spoiler alert, Connor wants to get paid. Okay. Ice beside crashing
out in his Discord this morning after finding out his girlfriend
had a like long-term relationship with Lav's husband. Okay. I
don't believe it involved cheating, although they did they did
hook up. Lav's husband and Kimmy, Ice's girlfriend, hooked up
while Ice and Kimmy were on a break. Okay.
Is he quitting? No, he's not. Uh, he's literally live right now.
Anyway, so this one doesn't matter. At the end of the day, you
Hey at Icepose, at the end of the day, you dodged a bullet. All
that did was help you realize it sooner than later. Arabana arc
or John 10 arc is going to be legendary. I wouldn't do a John
10 arc. I could care less about trying to women based. Awesome.
Uh, hold on. I might need to We're like too chubby on the need
to get less chubby here. Hold on.
Make this a little smaller. A little
And we'll zoom it out. There we go. Okay, we got everything on
the screen now. Perfect. All right. Uh, Goon lowkey saved you.
No, don't give Goon any credit. He could have messed with me.
He could have messaged me anytime in the past year privately.
He's a Oh, hold on. I've got a better idea than this. Give me
a second. I've got a better idea. Quick recap for the people
who weren't here yesterday. Okay, we'll do a quick recap. Okay,
hold on. Let me go to Clips Funkos. Let me go to Clips Von Clouse
and grab a quick recap. Okay, well, now all the punch is here.
off. >> We'll do a quick recap. Super fast recap. Okay,
we'll do a quick recap.
Just for anybody who wasn't here yesterday, if you missed it,
okay, is what happened yesterday. >> How about I drop you
guys? >> We don't want your
>> Whatever happened to that, you were supposed to take
the IQ test. What >> for the off chance that you have to
give the guy who girlfriend $30,000?
That's why we're playing this game. >> So, Lav drops the
first time. Says you we're playing this. We're doing this because
you got you're going to have to give the guy who [__]
your girlfriend $30,000 if we win. >> Okay, buddy. Good
one.
>> $2,000. The guy girlfriend $30,000. That's why we're
playing this game.
good one. >> So, should I drop the chest or not? >> And
for what? You have a You have a million and on a mattress with
no
>> dude. It's not It's not a mattress even. That's the
sad thing. It's just the floor. It's not the mattress. It's just
the floor. Well, I'm not sure. >> I'm not sure where you're
pulling that from, but I mean, you should talk about other things,
lab, that you have done yourself here.
>> Head chatter.
>> Who else? >> Talk about
>> Oh, yeah. Zirka head mods. Okay.
>> Like what? >> One beside >> one. Oh, god.
Heads. Okay. >> I don't even think you know what she was
up to. >> Oh, good one. All right. I think you might just
be projecting a little bit.
>> Why is she trying to emasculate him like that? What
the [__] Uh because because Ice Boseidon was talking
a lot of about them because they were talking about his event
and it kept ramping up and he talks about Lav being dumb and
that he could beat her in an IQ test and Lav kind of went the
off. Okay. As she does, okay, you talk some [__]
to Lav and Lav will sometimes go the off. All right. And she
did it again. >> Jesus Christ.
>> Hope you didn't. >> Lav's really pulling out all
the punches >> They are very upset. They are very upset
that they are losing. Guys, turn the >> I think Tazo's
close. Ice. >> Ice. I think >> I think Tazo's really
close. >> They are very upset.
>> Dude, it's He is coping so hard through this whole thing
cuz I think some some people are saying that he really believes
it that his girlfriend didn't [__] her here that
they're just talking >> Oh, that was close. >> Went
way too far for no reason. >> No, there's plenty of reason.
>> You don't know the scenes. Big dog. >> Yeah, the
little social espionage
on everybody >> on every woman who lying about me, lying
about every other girl. You guys want to hear the other leak?
I'll tell the Cubot leak now. Cubot was so sick and tired of
Kimmy that she put me up to the task to tell Kimmy that she couldn't
move back in because we had a history. >> Kimmy crashing
out at every single one of her friends that I besided messaged
when they broke up. >> Yeah, like it's just
>> it's really disrespectful to [__] on the
event organizer while participating in it. Maybe. I don't think
it's that disrespectful to like in the event like it's an ice
beside event. Of course, it's going to be scuffed. He should
expect a little talk. They should expect some talk back. Uh,
somewhere it crossed the line and I'm not totally sure where
Lav has a lot of problems with Kimmy, right? I didn't see you
can't see this as disgusting behavior. Jtock, I think it's I
think it's immoral behavior, but it's like totally in line with
this sphere of people. That's the thing, right? When in Rome,
do as the Romans do. Like there's morality is relativistic, right?
This is literally totally in line with what all of these IRL
streamers do. They constantly leak like this. They constantly
have blowups like this. I judge it, right? I can judge it from
a normal person's lens, but Ice Poseidon can't judge it from
a normal person's lens.
He's Ice Poseidon. He's built this entire sphere of people, right?
Like, I'm sorry, that's that's you. You can't build Okay, you
can't build a sand castle
next to the when the tide's out. All right, you can't build a
sand castle where the tide was. All right, and then when the
tide comes in and it gets washed away, you can't go, "Oh, what
happened? I don't How did this happen?" No, you built you built
there. You knew it was going to happen. You you know this [__]
will come back at you, right? >> Their whole is so stupid.
>> You guys want the clues for the next
>> No, like the the location in the house. Just make sure
>> Oh, yeah. Okay. Well, I'm going to just le ruin it for
everybody cuz I sucks at running events and I girlfriend by the
way. Give me Yeah, we we were roommates. So, just spread the
word. >> I'm not doing a analogy. No, >> the Discord
is still working on the
>> They were stunned. Yeah, they didn't know. They were
like w >> when we told chicken Andy he was like yeah so
is everyone else we were like we were like there's no way he
lets us get the 30k because he's like so is everyone else like
>> base goes crash out now >> it's your time base
goes he's speeding this event along >> you got to go >> he
only did that as you guys tried the >> base goes punching
his keyboard right >> dream hack I was like >> hey
you said something really nice to me two years ago like thank
you so much and she looked at me and she was like okay and I
was I >> I used to be like you're dumb and have be like
your child isn't yours. No. What pissed Lav off and I fully believe
this was Ice on Gunnar, right, repeatedly like Ice and Ice and
Lav were getting into it and then he started on Gunnar, right?
And Lav was like, "Oh, you're my husband." Well, my husband's
a better man than you. Okay? In fact, your girlfriend might have
problems getting wet for you, but she ain't got any problems
getting wet for my husband. Right? That's the kind of that Lav
was on, which is classic. Okay? That's classic [__]
That's fully expected. It's not my fault. It's not my fault Ice
doesn't do his due diligence. Okay. >> I was so taken aback
by how rancid it was. I've never Nobody has ever talked to me
like that before. And then crashing out at me because you didn't
text her back after she was like reaching back out to you in
what was it?
>> I've said it's I've said it's disgusting behavior. I
didn't say it's not disgusting behavior. I'm saying that the
only people who can't be mad about it are the people who have
engaged in this kind of behavior. Like Ice Pesidon and Sam Pepper
literally shill gambling to people and ruin lives constantly
and have both done crypto scams. Shut the [__] up.
Shut the [__] up with your moralizing for those two.
Okay, everybody else, you can moralize all you like. You can
go, "Oh, this is really disgusting." But for those two, you you've
done way worse things. Shut the
Okay, that's all. That's all. >> January months ago when
she was reaching out after she face up for the third time, by
the way. >> Yeah. And she was like, "Yeah, which you were
sweet." And you were like, "Hey, if you need anything, let me
know." Cuz she was on like watch or whatever. And then she was
like, "I really wish that I could move back in." And you didn't
have anything to say to her. And then she was getting mad at
me that you didn't text her back. And she was like, "You know,
I suppose I could leak it." Cuz I was
>> there's a small chance that this is what >> she
tried to threaten it like two weeks >> Yeah. So what Kimmy
basically had done through the is that say that maybe like he
like that Tim was like obsessed with her or something. They wrote
her love letters or something maybe to like pacify it for Ice
to like be less embarrassed by him >> and because it is
embarrassing to him >> when I was sleeping on the floor.
>> Oh, hold on. >> Reuben Ruben donated $3. Can't
connect a river to the ocean and then complain that all the freshwater
fish have died. >> Yeah. Uh there's another analogy. Thank
you, Ruben. Ruben, appreciate it, buddy. >> Um for in the
first six hours of meeting him, by the way. Like that's pretty
brutal stuff. >> Um and uh Yeah. So then Sam Pepper like
teases it when Ice drafting out and we're like and I'm getting
scared like oh is there a narrative that's like going to get
pressed and like all of a sudden we're not going to be on top
of it. I message her. I'm like, "Hey, I need to know what he
said." She's like skitstoing at me. Writes this whole big thing.
Whatever. Just isn't just so rancid to me. Only real people in
this space. Adriana literally the most down. So sweet. Maddie,
another sweetheart who Kimmy tried to blackball because Ice messaged
her. >> Oh yeah. >> Another Yeah. Telling you about
it. Telling you about it. How she was going to get her removed
from every single event just for being >> There's a reason
why Maddiey's not here cuz Kimmy's a psychop. >> I mean,
she probably also didn't want to do this because it was scuffed.
But like Yes. There's a reason why Maddie was not invited a lot
of places. Why she's not bigger. So apparently apparently Kimmy
Ice literally Ice literally confirmed this by the way that Ice's
girlfriend was like icing out other hot girls from events cuz
she didn't like how close they were getting to Ice >> that
she is and it's just because she's >> and blonde and replacement.
That was the fear. So >> yeah, I like just >> we
have no problem with the real people who are genuine human beings
just trying to make it. It's the people that take advantage of
those people come back. >> Yeah. And then there's so many
secrets cuz everyone >> Okay, hold on. I would say this
is the one reason that I think probably Kimmy should have told
Ice about this, right? Cuz like at minimum
>> Oh, hold on. We got a donation. We got Anonymous with
a gifted sub. Thank you very much. Anonymous. Thank you. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Uh, okay. So, yeah, this is like the one thing where I think
maybe Kimmy should have told Ice because maybe Ice could have
avoided some landmines with this, right? Or maybe Ice could have
just said it himself. Or they could have figured out some way
like you can figure out a way to like not make this hit quite
so hard. You don't want to be in a fight with people directly
where you're responding to them and then they go, "Yeah, but
this guy [__] your girlfriend." That that's like
that hits that hits a certain way, especially if you don't believe
it originally. Okay.
>> Just hits a certain way cuz he has a lot of money. He
puts events like this. >> We don't give a because we make
real money outside of this and we do this for fun to see our
friends. Yeah. There was a time where you needed like Poseidon
when you, you know, were younger, but >> it's changing
now. He's on his way out. Obviously, he can't throw together
good event. Can you do a sand pepper impression when he's covering
this all
>> What the goon? >> Wait, wait, they were roommates
3 years ago. She told me that he wrote her a love letter. >> Cha.
Chop. Is this real though, Cha? >> Ch. No. >> No.
Ch. This can't be crazy. Ch. >> This can't be real. Cha.
She said that he wrote her love letters and was obsessed with
her. She said she never had with him. Did Paul know? Did she
tell Paul? Chad, did you did he did she tell Paul? Oh my god.
Ch.
>> Anonymous tip. $3.33.
Never forget Ice took Kimmy back after Dude, you are >> Oh,
good one. >> No, that's complete.
>> Better now. >> They're just mad they're losing.
>> I wonder if he knew.
>> Uh, I don't know if that's him denying it, right?
Hold on. Let me listen to it again. Anonymous tip of $3.33.
Never forget I took Kimmy back after you are >> Oh, good
one. No, that's complete.
>> Like he didn't do that, right? So, I don't know if he's
saying no, that didn't happen or I don't know if he like he's
he could be denying that she cheated on him cuz she didn't cheat
on him, right? From everything I can see, she didn't cheat on
him. And the things that like kind of look like cheating are
not cheating. like it's h
it's like maybe in the it's like a mile outside of the ballpark
of cheating. Big buff is that they're funnier than most of the
people in CX. Yeah, I don't think most of the women like unfortunately
the CX stuff there's just no So with the CX stuff, there aren't
a lot of funny women. That's why Zena does so well cuz Zena is
actually funny, right? There's like hot girls who are interacting
with these people and they do stuff but they're unfortunately
they're like not super funny. At least from what I've seen. I
maybe I'm wrong, maybe I just don't watch their content, but
most of the hot girls who interact are like not funny at all.
Right? And I'm sorry, but it's way better content when you have
a girl who can talk. It's just infinitely better. Okay, Zena
can talk. She will talk back to these guys and she will roll
them, right? That's why she's funny. That's why she's good content.
Lav is the same. She can absolutely be super funny and roll some
people like conversationally or verbally. And she also like isn't
like super ugly or something, right? She's funny when she's random
citizens with a paintball gun. No, she's not. That's actually
her worst content. I don't know why she does that dumb [__]
She is funny when she's talking to people. I don't know why the
she does the stupid adds on to it. It's really disappointing
to be honest with you cuz she is very funny when she's just yapping
in front of a camera. It's very sad. Is MK funny? Murk's not
as funny. Murk's like in between. Let's see here. Yeah. Anyway,
we mad they're losing. I wonder if he knew. >> I wonder.
>> That's why That's why I asked her. That's why I asked
her. >> I literally like What did I literally like What
did you tell Paul? Cuz if if he's going to come out that like
with what Sam Pepper said, then like you got to get we got to
get ahead of this. Like >> Yeah, might as well. >> Yeah.
I wonder if she told him the whole group. It's fake. Ice confirmed.
She was my roommate for a year. >> She's not fake. >> We
shared a bathroom. >> Yeah. I never made it significant
to Paul. I vouched for her to be invited to events and things
that reason. Paul didn't want him around, but I said he wasn't
going to tell people and that I think he's a good person and
we'll remain respect. >> Lab just leaks these DMs. I don't
know how much more we need of this. Right. Lav like shows proof
that this happened and then we got Ice talking [__]
at the end of the day. >> And Lav have just dug a very
deep hole. >> we'll watch this and it's good that we get
this in because I don't want to just go into the DMs without
people or sorry the the Discord logs without people understanding
the context. >> I said you can enjoy your inflated viewer
account, >> but it is certainly not going to last very
long. There are some bridges that are just not worth burning
and Goon will forever realize that his wife had just this money.
So I hope it was worth it. >> Anonymous tip $3.33
ice. That's such a weak insult because Gunnar doesn't need this
for money. Like Gunnar's Gunnar's family runs a company. Gunnar
works for that company. Gunnar can always fall back into he can
like leave and come back as he likes, right? So like you could
you can go after Gunnar's stream or whatever, but it's never
going to like actually destroy him in some way. >> The
big fan, I feel sorry for you. You look like a loser and the
massive all because you can't get over Kimmy. She was never good
for you. >> Oh, I already texted Kimmy. I said I broke
up with her. I just texted her like an hour ago. This is cope
by the way. This is cope. This is cope. This is cope. This is
cope. This is cope. This is cope. >> We're done. So >> I'm
sorry. Someone keeps donating. >> I'm done with her. And
goon and lav are completely kick. I promise you that. >> I
would skip it. I'm sorry, but I'm looking for an ide. >> I
truly hope it was worth it. >> This is a thing Ice Poseidon
keeps doing. He's still doing it now. And I talked about this
last night with you guys. Okay. The only thing I the only way
I saw he could like that he had leverage is he could go, "Well,
I'm going to leave kick unless you get rid of them." They can't
bow to that. They cannot bow to that at all. They look totally
if they bow to him having a temper tantrum and saying, "Oh yeah,
you if you don't take these guys if you don't take these guys
away, I'm gonna leave. I'm going to go. I'm going to leave."
Yeah. No, you dude.
Eddie isn't a [__] Eddie explicitly like Eddie isn't
a [__] but he would work with these people, right?
If they don't crash out and make it a thing publicly where he's
like getting threatened publicly, he'll absolutely help them
out. But every single time where he like denies a creator, it
is always when they go public and try to pressure him into something.
As soon as they go public and try to pressure Eddie, they're
right.
No, he won't blackball them. He won't blackball them. He'll just
make them pay for it, right? Yeah, exactly. Zanakali, you know
it exactly.
Aiden Ross is like, "Oh, yeah. I'm going to I'm going to leave.
I'm going to go back to Twitch." And Eddie's like
Eddie's like, "Okay, you're banned from Twitch. What the you
going to do if you're not on kick? you go to Rumble like off
loser. Like I'm not I'm not dealing with this. It's so funny.
Can't get people banned, but you could get the KCIP messed with.
I think there's a huge difference, Nicks, in getting somebody's
KCIP bump down in punishing them, especially for something not
related to streaming, right? And getting it bumped up from like
some punishment going like, "Oh, forgive them." You can totally
go, "Oh, forgive them." And help them. But if you want to go
and be vindictive, you're going to need a reason. Especially
now that he's declared it publicly right now, if it actually
happens, Gar can go, "Oh, this guy literally got mad because
I said he his girlfriend. I did his girlfriend." Yes. This is
what I Ice can cut them out of events. Yep. Yeah. DC killing
spree. This is exactly it. If you if you
if you get his Casey, if they actually do that, that looks bad
for Kick. That looks bad for Ice. That looks bad for everybody
else.
And honestly, that makes Gunnar like a martyr. People are going
to flock to Gunnar's stream. Oh, Ice got so ass mad that you
took that he Ice got so ass mad that he with your money. That's
crazy. I'm going to come I'm going to come watch you think anyone
would go after them in litigation because he even said it. No.
No. No. No. >> Like I
don't have that much emotions. I can just throw under the bus.
>> This is not true. This is not true. And we're going
to see it when we go to his stream from today. Okay. And we look
at his Discord logs from today. This is last night by the way.
>> I don't like getting with. So if you me >> you
should expect to get with right back but in a different kind
of way. >> Captain Bllandon tipped $420.
Ice that's not a very good threat has been streaming like one.
>> I don't care dude but thank you for the >> Well
goons KCIP. >> Somebody somebody donated to Gary David.
Okay. Someone donated Gary David to with >> was about $1
for a very long time before the Hunger Games. I hope you enjoyed.
>> Sorry Z just linked this. Yeah. I don't I don't know
how you What do you even say? My husband [__] your
girlfriend on a mattress in a room without furniture. How do
you even respond without sounding mad? You can't. You can't.
And it's like it's over at that point. You break up with her.
Yeah. But the sad thing is is Ice literally like loves his girlfriend.
That's the sad thing. And he's got like Sam Pepper and his whole
audience who all are like Andrew Tate disciples telling him like,
"Oh, no, no, no. Like you're so right now. You're going to marry
this girl and give her millions of dollars when she [__]
this guy." She never [__] the guy when they were
like when they were together. She Gunnar when they were on break
and then possibly before that, but she didn't she didn't break.
She didn't uh she didn't [__] him when they were
together. She didn't cheat on him. That's I haven't even seen
Ice say that. I haven't seen anybody say that. He's still a No,
no, no. They're adults. They adults. This does not make you a
If you If you are not together with somebody, they [__]
somebody else and you get back together with them later. That
doesn't make you a cuck. That's But other people just can't stand
on business on this. You're so embarrassing if you can't stand
on business on this. He's not a But I'm not I'm going to call
him one
Okay. Yeah, I know. That is That is literally Faithless Follower
is at least honest. Okay. The rest of you aren't honest at all.
Faithless follower. He's just like, you know what? He's not a
but I'm going call him one anyway.
Uh, so the behavior here is him getting so mad about it and then
saying he broke up with his girlfriend over it and then he's
if he gets back to his with his girlfriend now because now he's
given a way that it like made him really mad. I don't know. I
can't imagine being this guy who's like, "Oh, you somebody else
like yours before we met or hung out? Oh, that's weird." Or or
like when we were broken up for a long time. Oh, that's I can't
imagine being upset about
I I literally can't I don't I don't understand the impulse. I
could totally I totally understand the impulse of like somebody
cheats on you while you're in a committed relationship and that
you up 100%. No, but she'd been bringing him around without him
knowing and all that. Uh there's a little bit there. There's
a little bit there. Yeah, but he fell he did fall into the bait
a little bit. Sorry. The the mattress thing was just brutal.
And then Gunnar talking her after the fact was also brutal. Okay.
Gunnar saying that she was his compulser. Brutal. Gar saying
that he was just using her for friction. Brutal. Brutal. Really
brutal. Even though he was just doing that to make Lav feel secure,
that was still very brutal. Okay. How long were they split? I
don't know. I don't know how long they were split for. It was
definitely a decent period of time >> with those $1 days.
>> We have 20 minutes, right? >> You know, Goon is
kind of the bad guy here, though, too. I just want Goon to know
that I fought for him in terms of bringing him to events and
bringing him to everything. Kimberly was always like, "Don't
bring him. I don't like him." And I was like, well, whatever.
I think he's funny. So, I always brought you to the events. I
always invited you to places and you want to try and me. >> I
don't know how how can you criticize Kimmy for bringing Gunnar
around and then also have this part where she's like, I don't
like him. I don't I don't get it.
>> But it's okay. You showed me that Kimberly is not the
girl for me, but you also showed me your true character with
your wife. This is the thing is now like once you say this and
then go back on all of it, you look like a total [__]
Right. So the thing is is I think he will get back with Kimmy.
I think he will.
But I you look like such a [__] now that you said
this. You didn't get caught by Goonar. You got by yourself. You
got you you are you are a in your own mind at this point, right?
And it's not because you got caught by Gunnar at all. It's not
cuz Gunnar Kimmy. All right. It's because you yourself. You're
in the basement of your own mind. In the in the in the chair
of your own mind. Okay. It's [__] >> So, I
will make sure to make it my mission in life to now destroy everything
that you and Lab have ever gained. And as for Kimberly, well,
I mean, I don't care what she does. >> That's also insane
jealousy. >> I messaged people to get you off the $1 KCIP.
I brought you to all these events. >> I think so. >> I
was like, "No, I think he's funny. I don't really see the problem
here." >> If not, we'll just combine forces. >> What?
Your character with your wife has been shown to be absolutely
disgusting because instead of messaging me
>> you've tried to clown me on stream. >> What? Dude,
okay, that's the other thing. This right here. Oh, why didn't
you message me personally? Uh, cuz that would be the weirdest
message of all time. Hey, Ice, I just want you to let you I just
want to let you know I [__] your girl. Hey, just
so you know, I your girlfriend. I hope it's not weird that I
your girlfriend, you [__] Oh. Uh, as an aside, guys,
we'll look at Gunnar's room one more time. As an aside, also
like the blastoff tweet pinned in the chat. Engage with the blastoff
tweet. Like the blastoff tweet. Retweet the blastoff tweet. Make
sure it's everywhere so everybody knows that we're covering this
stuff tonight. Okay. Like the blastoff tweet. Engage with the
blastoff tweet. It's pinned in the chat. Thank you very much.
This was Gooner's room. Again, just so we're all aware, this
was Goon's room when he was hooking up with Kimberly. And Ice
is telling them like, "I'm going to about to buy a Rolls-Royce."
And Lav's Lav's like, "Yeah, she she going her on a mattress."
And it turns out Lav was lying cuz it's not a mattress. It's
blankets on the floor. Okay. No mattress. Just blankets on the
floor. All right. Just gross floor blankets across the street
from across the street from Popeye's. Is Gunnar a big Popeye's
fan? Is that what I see there? No, no, no. This is Oh, I don't
even know what this is. I actually don't know what any of this
is. Wait, what is this? Somebody tell me what fast food this
is. I don't have this where I live. What a burger. What a burger.
Okay, he's a What a burger fan. So, across the street, I like
to think that they while this pile of garbage was here. Okay,
if you're a woman, okay, have the selfrespect to say, "I'm not
you until you clean that up." Please, for the love of God, at
bare minimum, can you do that for me? Could you just say, "I'm
not going to [__] you until you clean that [__]
up." That's gross. That [__] gross.
All right.
That's up. Please do not do that. That's That's crazy. All right.
Like I said, enjoy the inflated viewership for the time being.
At the end of the day, I am successful. You and Lab have on camera
for money, and it's not even that much money. So, it's just sad.
All right. Well, I'm going to let these guys sit here and try
to figure this out and marinate. I got to go deal with some stuff.
So, I'll be back tomorrow. All right. So, uh sorry to
>> uh That wasn't true. He does not come back tomorrow.
This is two days ago now. Then we had yesterday and now he went
live today. >> Ended this way. But I have some other things
that are very important to go handle. So, uh, I'm going to give
somebody a host here and I will see you guys tomorrow. I don't
think they're going to figure out the next few clues, so I'm
not really too worried about >> Guys, I got to go handle
this is made possible by contributions from viewers like you.
Thank you. >> Wow. Wow. Okay, so that's everything you
need to get up to today. Okay, we had an interview with Live
last night. I think Nick Wick Lee had an interview with Live
last night. Nobody else really spoke. And then Ice Boseidon broke
his silence today. Give me one second. Okay. Do you think the
condom pile was in that? Do you think the condom was in that
pile, too? Jesus Christ, dude. Gross. Gross. I hope he cleans
up. I hope he cleans up. Okay. All right. So, somebody asked
him if he's going to do his John 10 arc as going around trying
to a bunch of women. He's not going to do that. Okay. Don't give
Goon lowkey saved you. Don't give [__] any credit.
He could have messaged me any time in the past year privately.
He's a coward and a scumbag. Same with Lav. Uh he him messaging
you would have just made it weird. Why the [__] did
he message you, bro? How how and why should he message you? Maybe
at most he should have said, "Hey, Kimmy, can you make sure Ice
knows about stuff so it doesn't blow up later?" That's the most
he could have done. Okay, most he could have done.
Uh, why you acting like you didn't knew about Goon and Kim and
some Kimmy some Kimmy log here. I don't really care anymore.
I've been slandered for so long already. I know the truth and
I didn't lie and I didn't cheat.
Yeah, I don't think she I don't think she cheated at all. I'm
pretty sure she didn't cheat. Okay. I didn't know the extent
of their relationship. I knew they were roommates and they were
flirting and maybe something happened, but I certainly didn't
know they dated and were together for months and all all that.
Wait, I haven't even seen this substantiated. Gunnar didn't say
they dated. Nobody I've seen nobody say they dated. Why did he
say this? Where's the Where's the evidence they dated? They were
roommates for a year. They both lived with Cutebot, the streamer
Cubebot, and Jaw Millionaire in their house. Jaw and Cutebot
run a streamer house. They rent rooms to streamers, right?
And as far as I know, Gunnar a bunch of the streamers in that
house. Okay. If you're a female streamer, you lived in a house.
It just seems like that was uh that was that was part of your
rent. Maybe. I don't know. Okay. Uh yesterday, Cupid said you
were okay with it. Like you were a cuck. Lol.
Shut the f Ah. Okay. Cute is complete [__] who's
had multiple nose jobs and lies to all her friends, which is
why her friends hate her. Oh [__] Okay. I think this
screenshot's taken from our stream. Okay. Hold on. Let me go
let me go look to kick chat logs again. We pulled this up on
stream. I think this is just Yeah, this is this is a screen screenshot
from our stream. This is my timestamps. Bunch of bunch of Ice
Boseidon guys were watching the stream
Okay, I just pulled this up cuz Lav told me in the moment when
I was talking to Lav, she's like, "Yeah, Sam came into Goona's
chat and was trying to get him to leak all this [__]
back in June back in like Jul on July 1st." I was like, "Oh,
really?" And I just went and looked it up and it's like, "Yeah,
you should expose the truth now. It's the perfect time. It's
the perfect time for you to drop the gossip. Do it, Goon. It's
the perfect time. Drop the gossip. Come on, tell them it will
be content. It's time. Now, Sam later represents this as there's
a there was a rumor going around that Goonar wrote a love letter.
Okay. Oh, what's up, Cheese Beef? What's up, buddy?
Yeah, thank you. Spread the gospel, my friend. Thank you. Thank
you. All right, so there's some rumor going around that Gutter
sent some love letter or something to Kimmy. Okay, cheese beef,
by the way, discord.gg/jstlk.
Join the Discord. If you've got anything um any information I
need during the segment. If you're in the Discord, you can just
at me directly, throw it in the content suggestions or something,
okay? Looking for any any updates just in case I miss anything.
Okay, so this was right after Ice was kind of crashing out on
Kimmy. Sam Pepper came in was like, "Oh, expose it. Expose it.
Expose it." And Sam later says that this is about a love letter.
If Goon wrote a super embarrassing love letter to Kimmy, why
the [__] would he reveal that? Sam is totally full
of I think Sam knew they actually. I think Sam's totally full
of There's no reason you go reveal the super embarrassing information
about yourself. No sh
No, that doesn't make any [__] sense at all. He knows
that they [__] right?
There is no love letter. Sam was stirring. I don't know whether
there is or isn't a love letter. I've seen some people say it.
I I lean towards this though. Yes. That Sam is just making this
up or that Kimmy lied and told people that and then Sam later
found out that they did through somebody else. Okay. All right.
Anyway, so somebody at Ice Beside and says, "Look, Sam's trying
to Sam's trying to get people to Cheese Beef, who's in the chat,
says Sam's trying to stir, bro. He's trying to [__]
you over." So yeah, Cheese Beef, if you could go in the Discord
and link me the uh link me those messages that Kimmy leaked.
I have not seen those yet. I don't have those. All right, if
this is true, I'm getting Sam's event taken away. O, Ice is going
scorcher on everybody. I'm sick and tired of these people. All
scumbags.
That's I wonder if there's any introspection here. Like maybe
I've surrounded myself with bad people. Maybe I've made maybe
I've fostered an environment where only bad people can
Maybe only bad people can succeed in this environment and I've
created it and uh [__] me. Oops. But probably not.
If Kick wants to give money and opportunity to scumbags, I'll
just quit. Lol. I'm sure they choose me over Sam. This is such
a This is a mindset as well. Okay.
This is probably more than taking than taking Kimmy back if she
did cheat on you. This is the most mindset. I'm just gonna quit
and if they want me to stay, they have to get rid of these other
people. That's
behavior. Okay, that's [__] made the reacts. Yeah,
he's going to have to deal with this for a while. Okay, I know
Lav is Oh, also so he goes from that to on Lav. I know Lav is
extremely insecure about Goon getting with Kimmy. I've always
known Lav hated Kim and was insecure. She would message Kim about
how she's jealous of her, etc. So, make sure to remind Lav on
a daily basis that she was the second option. I'm pretty sure
Gunnar and Kimmy hooked up when Lav wasn't even around Gunnar
when they didn't even meet in real life. So, it's a little weird,
but okay. Okay. Maybe maybe uh in their marriage. So, super insecure
in their in their marriage. Why is this She was the second option
in their marriage. I don't know why he went in this order. That
is the order though. Okay. Hashira Strong says, "Dude, this is
100% cheating." She was responding to this to the guy she did
all that [__] with. That [__] So, in
this is January 12th of this year, I believe. Goar messages Kimmy.
Hey, Kimmy. I hope you're doing okay. Saw some stuff on Discord
about you that made me worry. Remember, I'm always a phone call
away or phone call or text away if there's anything you need.
Kimmy says, "So, this is about Kimmy's nose job. I believe uh
Kimmy obviously has a lot of hang-ups about her appearance. She's
had I a couple nose jobs and like that's obviously dude that
that's just [__] up to me. Okay, she's claiming they're
fine. Okay. All right. Thanks, Cheese Beef. Yeah. Uh so she responds
to Gunnar. I am completely disfigured. I made the biggest mistake
of my life and I cannot undo it. I scare myself when I look in
the mirror. I don't know how I'll ever come out of this. I don't
know how I'll ever come out of this. I've held it in and have
been strong for 3 months waiting on healing and trying to be
positive and feel good. And I finally have reached my low and
I cannot do anything I uh anymore. I am empty. Kimmy, you're
completely fine. You didn't do anything wrong. You're just overthinking
it because something right. So Gunnar's like just being nice.
By the way, this is super embarrassing for Gunnar. Okay. Goar
said he's just using her for friction. She's just a holster.
And then in January of this year, he's checking in like a good
boy. Okay. Now, I don't I'm not I'm not a loser, so I don't need
to pretend that this means he was in love with her, right? You
could just be concerned about her.
You could just be concerned for somebody who's your friend, right?
I don't think he's trying to [__] here. I I think
that's silly. But um I think he's probably just, you know, puts
on a character for stream. Okay. She was baiting to him. Wait,
is she I mean, I don't think this is baiting. This is like depression
baiting. It's like depression baiting. And probably she might
have been she might have posted about
Discord or on some Discord, right? and he was just like, "Hey,
I'm just checking in.
Sure, sure, sure, sure." Cheese beef. Now, unfortunately, like
this kind of um this kind of like body dysmorphia,
it's really [__] up. I have like sympathy for people
who have this, right? I don't I don't want to judge Kimmy like
that badly, but I don't I don't think this is him trying to like
slide in in DMs or anything. And I don't I think the person who
said this, the Hashir this Hashira strong guy, this is like loser
behavior that you're like, "Oh, this is 100% cheating." No, she's
like super [__] up and she's responding to people
who are giving her like positive feedback. Lav probably didn't
like that though. I don't know if Lav saw it. I have no idea.
Oh, I got a better version of this and I just read the super
[__] the super resolution version. Whoops. All right,
I'll keep that in mind for later. Okay, so Lav cried when this
happened. I remember Lav freaking out to Kim and I never understood
why, but Lav is very weak mentally. Uh logs. Can I get some logs?
You want to show me some logs of that? I would love to see the
logs of that. I'm just I'm not saying this isn't even true, but
Ice is like on the war path and he's saying things I I need some
evidence. Okay. Goon always loved Kim. I watched his stream back
in 2021 and he admitted it multiple times. I'm positive he still
loves Kim and would dump Lav now. Goon messaged Kimberly a year
ago when he and Kim broke up. When me and Kim broke up the second
time, he confessed his feelings and love for her and she denied
him that time and he was so mad he told her she can't move into
Cutebot's house. and he decided to marry Lav. Lav was second
option. Okay, show proof. Show proof. Show proof. Show proof.
Uh, no, I'm not debating you on that slime. We're literally doing
drama right now. What are you talking about? Show me. Show me
proof. All you got to do is show me proof. And if you don't show
me proof, just talk to them, right? Talk to them directly and
ask if this happened. Show anything.
Show anything. There's a bunch of stuff getting leaked that like
could conceivably make Ice look better to some people, but it
none of it has any proof. And every time I see it, I'm just like,
"Oh, this is cope. This is cope. This is big time cope. Massive
cope. Massive cope. Massive cope. Massive cope." So, I don't
know for sure. It just unless I see evidence of any of this,
it's massive cope. Okay. This is drama sl This is a drama slap
stream, little bro. Yeah. I hope you're responding to slime 712.
Okay. Cuz yes, this is this is absolutely drama slap stream right
now. Okay. Don't come to me and ask me to debate policy. The
[__] We're covering some fun [__] right
now. Okay. Okay. Nope. It's good too for airing it out publicly.
Talk about fault. I mean, I should have respected him more instead
of dogging him out the whole event so far. Not everybody's going
to be a [__] and let you talk about them non-stop,
especially when he his girl. Huh? Okay. So, he's a You can't
take banter. Got it. Technically, Gunnar didn't bring this up.
Okay. Technically.
Technically.
Stopping to debate singlepayer healthcare right now is hilarious.
It could be. It could be.
Uh, no. I'm not going to do it. I'm not going to do it. I'm not
going to do it. I would be [__] up, bro. I Gunnar
didn't reveal this, okay? Lav revealed this. And you could be
really mad that Gunnar talked to Lav about it, but also you can't
you have to pick one, okay? Gunnar told Lab that he [__]
your girlfriend. And either that's okay or or it was really up
for him to say it. And Kimmy didn't have to tell you. You'd either
be mad. Okay, you get to pick one. Pick one to be mad at. Kimmy
for lying to you or Goonar for telling the truth to his girlfriend.
Pick one. You can't do both. Either it's okay to tell your partner
about it or it's not. And Lav was the one who revealed it. So
jeez. Show proof we're leaking everything else here. Show proof.
I'm guessing Cheese Beef is asking for proof of the previous
log about Kimmy Lab being mad at Kimmy, right? I don't have that
proof. It's in Kim's phone. She lied to you again. Now I remember
seeing it. Add Boseidon 69. Can you commit 100% right now today
to not pulling a Caroline 2.0 and carrying on a hidden relationship
behind our backs?
You should touch grass. Uh translation.
No, I will not commit to [__] for you. Do you? I
mean, he took it for 3 to four days. Why would he keep taking
disrespect when in the back of his mind he knows what he did
to Kimmy? Treat people how you want to be treated. He would never
have said anything. Dude, these people all think of women as
like property. Why would he take your disrespect when he knows
what he did? He knows he spray painted your He knows he left
a a street tag on your woman. Okay. He knows he spray painted
that [__] spray spray painted her insides, bro. He
knows he what he did. He knows what he did. He vandalized your
property, Ice, because it's just banter and I've given the dude
this dude a good opportunity and helped him grow his money. Uh,
I mean, bantering back. Yeah, I I think Lev went way too hard.
You think these ninjas were in prison or something? All right.
If Kick wants to give money an opportunity to scumbags, I'll
just quit. Lol. I'm sure they choose me over Sam. Oh, somebody's
upset about that. I mean, Kick would tell you to close the door
on the way out. Strong arm for the wrong reason. Strong armed
for the wrong reasons. Sam stuck up for you after it happened
and turned on the stream and made Goon and Lav look tiny in a
call. Uh
I mean Sam Sam went and did propaganda for CX viewers, right?
That's what Sam did. Sam turned his stream on and he did blatant
propaganda for Ice Boseidon viewers, right? I don't think Sam
was being very honest there. Jaytock does not even know the lore
of Horseshoe Bay. I don't Oh, I'm new. Help me out, bro. Is this
Is this the Horseshoe Bay lore right here? The Caroline 2.0?
I don't know it. I don't know it. [__] me. You guys
got a wiki or something? Can I Can I read some lore? It was a
crazy time. Well, maybe maybe we'll have to look some up. Okay.
Maybe we'll have to check some [__] out after this.
All right. No. I said if I was wronged by a streamer and wanted
to stop streaming, I'm sure they'd take my side. Okay. But that's
just you saying you're strongarmming them. That's you saying
you're a [__] That's you passively strongarmming
them too, which is even more made. At least just come out and
say, "Hey, kick kick them out or I'm I'm gone." Don't go, "I'm
going to quit streaming. Maybe if you got rid of Sam, I'd be
feel like coming back to streaming." Don't do that. That's so
[__] made, dude.
Come on. You had a secret relationship and then it all came out
on a stream and there was a huge blow up at a resort in Texas.
Oh well, whatever. I don't care. I'm disappointed in Kim and
Goon and Lav. It's all disgusting and I need to focus on just
finishing this event. That's everybody. Everybody can enjoy that.
Everybody can like that. Okay. Uh no, if I said I was wrong by
a streamer wanted to stop streaming, I'm sure they take my side.
But what did Sam do if he knew it was not his place to tell you
either way? It was Kim's. I just This person means what does
Sam do wrong? I just feel Sam has been on your side with the
when the news broke out. Sam's farming. Okay.
Apparently, he was in goons chat telling him to say all that.
Ah, and then Sam Pepper hops in. Okay. Sam Pepper Hopson to the
Discord. Bro, I was just winding him up about the love letter.
I wasn't trying to start anything. I kept that quiet for a year
along with the Jamie. Why you always got to point the finger?
I don't know what the Jamie is necessarily, but Sam is just like
lying here. This is not this. Why would you go to somebody's
chat and go, "Hey, that really humiliating thing you did. You
want to like you want to leak all that? You want to talk about
the humiliating thing you did, guys? Hey, good talk about how
you were like totally humiliated when Kimmy rejected you. That
doesn't make any sense. I didn't that cheese beef. I didn't look
through Sam's logs. Um, yeah. This makes no sense. Don't let
Sam lie to you guys, okay? This makes zero sense. There's no
reason he would have done this. He's totally He knew they he
probably talked to somebody else other than Goon, Cutebot, whoever.
Right. That's almost certainly what actually happened here. Okay.
Oh, I've got those logs. Cheese beef, but thank you. All right.
Sam's Sam's full of right now. Okay, Sam's totally full of [__]
And Ice response, you were in his chat saying leak [__]
Nah, I don't believe it. Lau, but the love letter. Come on, bro.
That's some cap. Even if it was a month ago. Why you pushing
that? Don't believe that? How the [__] would I know
anything else? That was months ago. Them logs.
Uh, those logs make no sense for what you say they they mean.
Those logs don't make any sense at all. Zero sense. No sense.
Or Okay, I've got a couple YouTube videos for this. I also >> What's
up, guys? How you doing? >> Quick quick short preview of
this. Okay, I need 60 seconds. I got to take so badly. I drank
so much caffeine before the stream. Give me a second. >> Let
us address the drama and what's going on because I see it all
over Reddit. We got this nice resort here for all of us. Uh not
just for all of us, but for a couple ladies of mine.
>> What are you guys doing? >> Leave. You need to
leave. >> What are you guys doing? What's going on? What's
happening here? You guys, you guys have to have consent after
>> Oh, no. Don't worry. I'm [__] both these
girls. Don't worry.
>> Kaye, let's go. Why you Why you talking to her? Come
on, >> Kaylee.
Let's go. >> Come on, Kayie. Let's go.
>> Come on. Let's go.
>> Let's go on the boat. What?
>> I'm doing what? >> Oh, I'm back. Jesus Christ.
But okay, so I was only listening to that, okay, as I walked
away. So is he talking about both of these girls when he's actually
dating one of them? Like obviously that's going to piss somebody
off, right? If you if you say you're both of these girls when
one of those girls you're in a relationship with. Yeah, I can
see exactly how this blew up. Jesus Christ. Okay. Oh, thank God.
Feel relief. Feel relief now. I'll also keep in mind that Misk
is the cameraman here.
That is very funny.
Okay. How would I know anything else? That was months ago. Them
logs. That was months ago. Them logs, says Sam Pepper. Well,
I'm at the point where I'm on guard and don't trust anything
anyone says. So, well, you shouldn't trust him. He's blatantly
lying. Uh, I don't give a [__] I will destroy these
people. Cancelling people is still not a good look. I don't give
a [__] I will destroy these people. Godamn. Yeah,
it's Yeah, exactly. Five weeks ago. Exactly. Cheese beef. Exactly.
Shouldn't be mad at Goon at all. Kimmy was single and he thought
Ice knew. So what? Can't blame the guy because your girl's a
lying hoe. Um he said Kim was a [__] bucket and [__]
holster or holster actually. Although maybe [__]
bucket too and all this. So even if Kim was the one in the wrong,
he was still disrespectful and saying things to make me look
bad. Bro, also just keep in mind every time Kim is insulted,
Ice Boseidon says it's to make him look bad, right?
Oh, this is brutal. This is not good. Okay. This is not good,
guys. This is not good. This is not good. This is not good. It's
not good. It's not good. Oh boy.
So, so basically that's like you again. See,
this guy's talking about your girlfriend instead of being like,
"Dude, don't talk [__] to my girlfriend." That pissed
me off. He's like, he's saying all these things to make me look
bad. What? Bruh. Brh. Yeah. I don't care anymore. They're all
dead to me. And at the end of the day, I'm the one who will be
happy and all of them will be miserable.
At this point, I'm going to finish the event and I'm going to
take a long while to be to be to myself. This is all toxic and
I don't have to deal with this anymore. I've been lied to by
everyone left and right after doing my best to try to build everyone
up. So, I'm over I'm so over it. It's so hard to even focus on
the event. I'm completely embarrassed and I feel so deflated
and so angry at everyone. Uh, this is real. I man like I I do
feel some level of empathy for this guy, right? Like
obviously he feels up and he's built a community where like you
can take whatever somebody's insecurity is and pick at it and
pick at it and pick at it, right? So he already knows that he'll
get no peace if he's streaming like he will he will get zero
peace. He will be with endlessly, right? Yes. Cope winter green.
Yes. I I don't feel bad for him that he's going to get farmed
and he's going to get made fun of. Right. I don't feel bad for
him on that. I just feel bad in general that like he's he feels
bad. I just feel human empathy for that. Anyway, uh at ice Ice
Poseidon 69, you won't be embarrassed when you continue to count
your millions and you find someone who actually gives a about
you and Ice another non- cope message. Okay. Yeah, money is great
and in the end I'll be living a happy life while all these toxic
losers are miserable grinding for their next payday or viewership
boost. But in this moment, I feel very up and so so angry. You
guys keep talking about other women that I don't want to be with
any women. It's so also not worth my time. Grog W.
True, brother. True.
I don't care about getting any [__] any girls. I
would just ra I would rather just be alone at this point. Oof.
Oof. I've been there, bro. I've been there. That's rough. That's
rough. No, no, no. This is like This is just venting. This is
real. This is like venting. I get it. I feel it. Goon and Tav
were so eager to Goon and Lav were so eager to air it out on
stream. They've been edging all event. They know what they were
doing. Please [__] up their entire lives. Or sorry,
[__] their entire lives up. Scumbag people. Ice responds.
Their lives were already and I don't need to do anything to be
honest. He lives off his wife's only fans. He is not a man. He
is a leech and a coward.
Wow. Real this. Wow. Wow.
You can take Kimmy back. I give a [__] You can take
Kimmy back. I give a I think she's not a bad person at all. Sometimes
people just meet others who give them what their partner doesn't
and that's just how it is. Better find out what you can't give
her. Uh that's a weird message
because they again if you're cheated on, you can feel really
bad. I don't know why I don't know why this guy would say it.
Ice totally in control of his emotions.
Oh, when the pit overflows
sometimes it happens, man. The pit does overflow. Kimmy alt.
Yeah, I don't know. Ban is the biggest most responded to. Okay.
Nah, she wasn't fully honest with me and I asked if she had any
relationship with people when we got back together. I don't think
I don't know that they dated. I haven't heard that they dated
at all. Kim put me in a position to be embarrassed and give someone
leverage over me without me knowing that's up and I can't forgive
that. When I spoke to Kimberly, she kept saying she never lied
to me and kept saying I knew that's the worst part. She can't
just be honest even still. Uh she never lied to me and she kept
saying I knew that's the worst part. So he feels like he didn't
know. I don't know if Ice realizes it. People do [__]
outside of long-term dating. Relationship means any contact.
But she said she [__] him. Ice did not not know that
they
was about the dating. He says it's about the dating. He admitted
earlier in these vlogs he knew that they probably hooked up.
He says that himself. By the way, the community always tries
to pressure Ice to break up with his girlfriend because his content
gets worse if he's in a relationship and he's more lazy. I haven't
seen him be lazy with Kimmy, but maybe I I haven't been watching
that long. So, what more embarrassing Ice Boseidon is? What's
more embarrassing at Ice Boseidon is that you're still showing
you you're still showing you still care about her and have feelings
towards her. Yes, you being a human is [__] made.
Bro, have you considered that you shouldn't care about women
at all? And you're being a [__] I'm not a robot.
Obviously, I have feelings for Kim, but that's why I'm so angry
and upset that there's no way I can salvage this. There's just
no way. My feelings are so conflicted, but I haven't got a choice
here. She tried to gaslight you. I know that. I believe that's
where this ends. Okay, that's where it ends.
ends there.
At some point during this, we get Sam Pepper booting up his stream
and going live. Okay, Sam Pepper boots up. Yeah, >> he
goes live. He looks at the logs with >> This This is about
the love letter. That was it. >> It was a love letter.
>> Nah nah nah. >> Yes, I knew about the love letter.
Yes, I knew everything. I wanted it to come out. >> No,
but think logically you said tell them about the letter.
>> Tell them about the letter. Exactly. I know. I would
have said tell him about who you I know. >> Do we get confirmation
of Kimmy's
I'm pretty sure Ice confirmed this. Yes, we've got multiple people
who have >> I I knew about the letter. That's it. I like
I just >> mean it says tell them about the letter in the
text. >> I know, but obviously that got cut out of the
>> What? No, it didn't. Ah, did he did he HTML edit this
or did I just not see it? Uh maybe maybe I just didn't see it.
Uh bro, no. This is kick chat logs right here. He just HTML edited
whatever site that is, didn't he? He just This is the This is
the exact proof he's lying. He absolutely just HTML edited this.
What a piece of [__] What a piece of [__]
How did he pull this up?
>> Hold on. >> What site is this?
that's I deleted them. How How am I going to delete past messages?
Yeah. >> I Dude, I don't think so. Why would why would
kick chat logs have it and this site not sorry not have it and
this site would that doesn't make any sense to me that doesn't
make any sense to me what are we talking what do we know what
site this is
>> what site is this
>> uh Sam let me see maybe I did search
>> is it just this like right okay >> search messages
username
Sam Search this
>> chat message search. >> I'm assuming that's I
deleted them. >> How am I going to delete past messages?
>> Channel name goon. >> Yeah, this is it. That's
what I said. >> Oh, I didn't go back far enough. Whoops.
>> This is about the love letter. That was it. It was a
love letter.
>> I cuz I'm concerned Kick Chat logs doesn't have every
message they miss. Are Are you sure?
Are you sure? Or do they not include things that get
>> Tell them about the letter. It's time. Yes, I knew about
the love letter. >> Yeah, but we've got these logs over
there. That's the only thing. Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on,
hold on. Even if he said it, by the way, that still doesn't change
my mind. That still wouldn't change my mind at all on him like
knowing that there's more there. Like, it wouldn't change my
mind even a little bit. Apparently, it's there. Oh, man. I don't
know. It's time. It will be content. Come on, tell them it's
time. And then we just missed the two. We just missed the one
message. It will be content. It's time, bro. Really? We just
missed that one message. I guess what you could do if there was
a way to click into this chat, right? You could just go to this
exact time stamp, right? If we do this, uh, hold on.
This is uh 06
21.
Uh,
okay. 2147. Oh. Uh, so this would be what? 11:47.
And we could go to July 1st. Hold on. This going to this is going
to make sense in a second. I don't want to filter. I don't want
to filter. Oh, I do want to go to Goon's channel. Sorry. I want
to go to Goon's channel. Did I not Did I not do this correctly?
Whatever. You know what? [__] it. I don't care anymore.
I don't care anymore. Interesting. Does it keep messages deleted
by mods? That's what I'm thinking. Uh, you can check your own
logs from kick itself and like cross reference and see how messages
don't get listed on kick chat logs. Okay, that's crazy that the
one message got got missed, right, about the letter. That's unlucky.
By the way, I still don't think any of this makes any sense,
right?
Like I think even if he says it's about the letter, I think that's
him covering himself that he knows there's more there. It has
to be. It doesn't make any sense otherwise.
Hey, you know when you like got rejected by this girl? Drop the
drop the drama on this. It doesn't make any sense anyway. That's
all I know. >> But I will give it to him that there is
more everything. I wanted it to come >> No, but think logically
you said tell them about the letter. >> Did you know that
>> tell them about the letter? Exactly. I >> I would
have said tell them about who you [__] No, I I knew
about the letter. That's it. I like >> uh this would be
another thing. Yes. If messages that get deleted don't show up.
That would be interesting, right? If somebody deleted that message,
that would be very very
tell them about the letter in the text. >> I know, but
obviously that got cut out of the >> Bro chat logs. You
failed me. You failed me massively. >> What happened to
you? I said that. >> You failed me totally. >> This
is the only time I've ever spoken in this chat. >> Well,
it's important we watch this then. is actually a big deal. >> You
whole gummy. I assumed that they had been I just assumed that
been >> okay. There you go. That like that. There you go.
Right. So, he's saying release it all and then he says it's the
letter and then he says, "Well, I assume they've been." Yes,
that's what you wanted him to leak. Come on, man. >> I
just assumed like, bro, if she if he's writing love letters then
to like had a bingo the site. >> I don't think I've ever
written a love letter to someone that I didn't have like a relationship
with, you know? I thought that was like it's so hard to even
focus on this event. Is he really canceling the event? There's
no way. So, this was him. He was arguing with uh he was arguing
with Ice in the chat. Okay. All right. That's really about it
from Sam. I mean, Sam does watch uh Ice when he goes live as
well, but I think I think I'll listen to Ice and maybe if there's
some Sam commentary that's important, we'll bring it up. But
we're ready, guys, for the big the big attraction today. I didn't
even pre-watch this, okay? I just want to react along with you
guys. Ice Boseidon
goes live today after the day off. He took a day off. He got
his head together, then he came back. Okay, he is back. He's
ready to go.
Here he is. And he for about 30 minutes just talks about um talks
about this whole thing. Okay, he is back. He talks about it.
And I do want to see this head is not together. Yeah, I know.
I know. Uh from what I've heard, this doesn't this isn't great.
Okay, this is not great. It's not the best, but I'm I'm still
excited to see it. Okay. And I waited to watch it with you guys.
I didn't want to watch it by myself. No pre-watching. Okay, we
just wanted to >> Oh man. Oh
man, I uh I really really
did not want to go live. I really don't want to be here. I'm
not going to lie. But I have an obligation to all the contestants
competing in the scavenger hunt to give them, you know, the uh
event and finale. Try to try to, you know, >> keep the
event going, try to finish up the event uh at a normal pace.
>> I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Ice, please don't get my KCIP
taken away. It has to go >> That it was originally supposed
to be. But I am very angry, very upset. I am mentally, emotionally,
completely scattered, completely
uh you know, I've been I've been made to be I've been made out
to uh as a fool. I'm completely
>> Dude, I'm sorry.
Maybe I have a different read than everybody else. This sounds
like it's like a really bad actor.
I I like from the messages I fully believe he's up, but this
sounds like awful. I I This doesn't sound believable at all.
>> Um I look like I just look like a fool. I I didn't sleep
for 40 hours yesterday. I couldn't sleep. >> I didn't sleep
for 40 hours. Okay. >> I've been over by people who are,
you know, close to me. I've been lied to by people who are close
to me and my >> He's just a I got you. >> And I I
have to just put all of that aside to try and focus on this event
and the scavenger hunt, which is a very hard thing to do.
But, you know, I owe it to the >> Well, to be fair, Alien
Mode, he didn't take a bunch of Adderall and sit at a computer
for 10 hours to figure out how many hours are in the day. Okay,
that's how he came up with the riddles. contestants to do that.
Um, you know, I don't know what else to say. I am
you know, I am in a I am completely a wreck right now. My mentally
and emotionally, I am a complete wreck. I >> have so much
anger. >> That feeling of being betrayed. Keep your head
up, homie. >> I have so much anger behind me.
I
just want
everybody and the entire world to just burn right now. I really
do. >> Two arrests. >> But dude, I didn't know that
Darius just bases his entire persona off of Ice Besidon crashes.
Like every time I've seen Ice Beside Up, he types and acts the
exact way Darius does like 50% of the time. It's like 2% for
Ice, it's like 50% for Darius, but it's the exact same persona.
Ina and Zoo's drunk driving racial slurs white boy summer last
night. >> I have to be the bigger man here
and I have to just try and focus on the scavenger hunt. Okay.
I could sit here and I could attack people. I could sit here
and go after people, say crazy about people. >> I hope
you do. That's literally what I'm here for. That's that's why
we're here, man. That's That's what we're all here for. Please.
But that's what they want. That's what every That's what all
these people want. These people who are very toxic. That's what
they want. >> They want the attention. They want to be
talked about. Any publicity is good publicity to them, you know?
And then Kimberly, I mean, there's nothing to say there. There's
just no there's nothing to say about her. I I just I have nothing
to say. It's I'm just disappointed and hurt and I I mean, what
do you say? You know, the I could sit here and I could just [__]
on her. I could [__] on Goon. I could sh on Lav,
but that's just a I mean, what what there's What am I supposed
to do? I mean, it's just not worth my energy. It's not worth
it. It's just these people are just >> I mean, it would
be worth your It would be awesome. Could you just do Could you
just do the content, man? What are you What are you doing? What
are we doing >> Just bad people and this is what they want.
There's just nothing
that I can do that without I mean I would just it >> I'm
so I thought she cheated. She didn't even cheat. What the [__]
are people so mad about? I think she probably, you know, had
those texts back and forth with Gunnar in January that weren't
great, right?
I don't know. We could see. We could see
and maybe maybe more stuff will get leaked based on some of this
because Kem said she might go live. That would be exciting. Okay.
Um but I don't know. From everything I've seen, there's no allegation
of cheating. There's no actual allegation of cheating. It's just
like she lied to him about how much she [__] her.
That's it. That's it. This Ninja did so much. Talks about bad
people. Yeah, I know. It's just >> me to their level. I
mean, it's and it's just what they want. It's it's it's, you
know, it's tough. It's real tough. You know the thing that really
bothers me though is that you know Goon
this guy I have given so much opportunity to so much money
you know I helped him try to get his KCIP fixed when it was a
dollar an hour >> retardation just tipped $5.
>> Did you mean what you said about Connor's motivations
to stick with Epstein? disavow that obviously
>> Okay. You like something I >> All right. Uh, thank
you for the Thank you for the donation. Appreciate it. Uh, I'll
have to look that up in a second. >> I brought him to the
Hunger Games. >> All these things,
gave him stake streams, you know, because he has zero dollars
in his bank account. He told me he's poor, has zero dollars in
his bank account. I gave him a stake stream to give him a chance
to make money. Hey, whoever just donated that, the imager link
does literally doesn't work. What are you doing, bro? What are
you doing? That album is broken. >> I just, you know, I
did so much to help that dude. And all I got in return was him
holding something over my head that I had no idea about. Except
he didn't do that. His wife did that objectively.
He He with you after, but that's that's him rolling with the
punches, dude. I don't know. I don't know how much you can hold
that against him. Yeah, he said some really mean about Kimmy,
but like he didn't hold it over your head >> for the past
year until he saw >> this is true. This is true. >> An
opportunity where he felt like he didn't need me anymore so then
he could try to use this against me to try to gain viewers from
it. Okay. He married this girl, >> right? And who do you
think told that to his wife? Okay. So, is Kimmy up for not telling
him about the relationship or was Gunnar up for telling his partner
about the relationship? You can only pick one. Only one of Goonar
and Kimmy can be evil. So either Kimmy should have told Ice or
Goonar shouldn't have told Lav. Pick one
Lav. He makes money off of his wife's only fans now. So he's
like, "Well, I can live off my wife's only fans even though they're
all leaked online. You can watch it completely for free and you
don't need to buy her Only Fans." And she sucks dog
as shown on the internet. If you search her name, you'll see
a video of her sucking a small little dog.
>> That's a just to be clear, that's a female dog.
So like she's at most eating the box of a dog. Okay, that's that's
the most you could accuse
>> on video.
Okay, he lives off his wife only fans now. So he didn't he felt
like he didn't need me anymore. So he complet he hel withheld
information
to throw me under the bus. >> This is not good. This is
not good. This is not good. This is not good. I'm It's already
not good, dude. He's uh he's paranoid and just look at his eyes.
Like he's not slept. He's paranoid and he doesn't trust anybody.
It's not good. >> He lives off his wife only fans now.
So he didn't he felt like he didn't need me anymore. So he complet
withheld information
to throw me under the bus. Dude, it's he
there's no evidence of that, right? He didn't do that to throw
you under the bus. And I I just I fully believe anybody who sits
here and is like actually he should have come up to Ice and said
I your girlfriend once. That totally would have been a normal
interaction. That totally would have been the the manly thing
to do.
Why? >> At a certain point, which is completely
disgusting after everything that I've done to help that dude.
If you were a real man, you would have came to me manto man a
year ago and you would have told me, you know, hey, why tell
Stream? He didn't tell Stream.
His wife told Stream. Holy [__] >> I just want
>> I'm going to have to start a flowchart for people. It's
like, uh, was it wrong for Gunnar to tell Lav? And then if yes,
then then Kimmy is okay for not telling Ice everything, right?
And then we like loop back. It could be the easiest flowchart
for absolute morons who post in this chat right now. >> Want
to let you know this is the situation. Instead, he held the information
until he saw an opportunity
to try to get one over me, which is disgusting. I have been over
by so many people in my life, but I will I mean I I will say
this is probably the worst betrayal anybody's ever done to me
to me over. Why is the guy acting like he wasn't 100% alive?
He was. That's his wife, bro. That's his wife. That's Those two
are together. Once his wife Once his wife pulls the pin on that
grenade and throws it in the trench. Okay. He's got to start
He's going to start laying down covering fire. That's what you
do when you get married.
Right. What is it? Uh, in good times and bad. All right. In good
times and bad. In sickness and health. Okay. >> I just
cannot believe it. The people in this world are disgusting.
I go out of my way to try to help all these small streamers,
get viewers, try to make
Yeah, I may, you know, have banter. I may I make fun of people
and, you know, whatever. It's all just content banter. But there's
a line and he crossed that line instead of just being a man and
coming to me manto man. You are a coward
and honestly you deserve nothing but the >> I realistically
like what he So if he wanted to say it's absolutely disgusting
that you'd say these things about Kimmy. Uh cuz like that's my
girlfriend. [__] you. If he wanted to say that that's
being a man, okay, that's being a man. Like you, okay? If you
want to say that, that's why you're mad. But he's like, "How
dare you say those bad things about my wife? How dare you call
my wife a pollster and a [__] dumpster? That just
makes me look bad. How dare you attack me like this? It's like
what? You're not mad that he said it to your wife. You he made
her feel like you're mad that like you look bad because he said
she's a bolster. Really? >> Obviously Kimberly is the one
who withheld the information, you know, for a long time.
She is the one who is ultimately at fault here. But Goon
should have been a man and told me a year ago what the was going
on. Especially after everything that I've done for that dude.
It is It is
up. I can't believe it. I don't know how I'm going to feel I
don't know how I'm ever going to feel better about this or get
over this. I have no idea. I have no TR. Dude, it's like he's
actually making it so much worse for himself by catastrophizing
like this on stream, right? He's making it so much worse for
himself
right now. Ah, he all he had to do is not act like he got [__]
over. He didn't get [__] over. All come on stream,
figure out the timeline. Come on stream and say, "Yeah, they
were on break and it's really like they're good is disgusting
for talking about my girlfriend that way, but I can't be mad.
We were not together. We were not together at all." I'm She didn't
tell me. But like that's way worse or sorry, that's way less
bad than her having cheated on me. >> Trust for anybody
anymore. I don't trust anybody. I don't want to help small streamers
anymore. I don't want to give money to small streamers anymore.
I don't want to help people anymore. I'm completely
over it. He said he wanted to do Hunger Games. Yeah, you're a
scumbag, goon. You are a scumbag. and you will be the reason
me
Ice Poseidon is not going to help small streamers anymore. I
will not go out of my way to help people
because I don't >> It's all Gunnar's fault that we're not
going to do events anymore, guys. O, >> that is probably
going to put him on the on the outs with a lot of people, right?
>> Trust anyone and I have to now try and get over this
grow. He's been dropping charity chests all day. But since, by
the way, this leak turned him from PT Barnum into Mr. Beast >> from
this and mentally
be able to recover. I I just have been completely over. So, I
just want everybody on kick to know that
you will not be getting any more opportunity from any big streamers
because I'm the only one who gives small streamers opportunity
and I will no longer do that now. Okay, he does give small streamers
opportunities and some small streamers have gotten a lot bigger
because of his help, right? He's uh this is true, but at the
same time, it's like don't act like you don't benefit. Don't
act like you don't make a money off of like this. Okay, come
on, dude. You're making so much money off of this. You're making
so much profit off of running these events. Let's not [__]
around, dude. >> And it will be Goon's fault. And I will
be sure to let Eddie and every buddy at kick know that I refuse
to
help the community on kick any longer because I don't trust anyone
anymore. It's not worth it. I have made
so much
success in this world. I have made
I I am so I just don't need to do this anymore. I'm just so
and I have done so much good in the past 10 years in the streaming
world and I have made a life for myself that I can be proud of.
I have made money for myself that I can be proud of and I just
don't need to deal with this. I don't need to go out of >> That's
totally fine. I don't know why he's crashing out over like this
specifically. If you if you feel like this, like he hasn't even
successfully set up his green screen, but okay, dude. I Yeah,
it is just cope, right? Like he does these events because he
makes a bunch of money and it's fun. It's fun for his community.
There's nothing better for a community than some like united
purpose, right? He gets his whole community together that people
join in. I I was never in Ice Besides Discord. I joined Ice Besidon's
Discord just to go and like get memes from this to go and track
like the messages. It's a huge community event. He grows massively
off of it. I don't know why he's pretending like he only does
this as charity, right? I get that it's stressful, but it's like
you're doing so little work and making so much money. It's crazy
to then come out and complain like you're not getting the you're
not massively benefiting from all of this, right? Sure, Dingling.
This >> is my way to help people. This is just
completely up. >> It's really not. >> But I have
an obligation to finish the scavenger hunt, so I'm going to do
that. But I I just don't know how I can possibly ever >> learn
to trust people ever again.
>> There's no way I can ever trust people ever again. I've
been over so many
>> My bad, bud. Kickbot removes the numbers from the URL.
>> Obviously, highest https-short
link.me
>> Okay, that's uh certainly not suspicious at all. in
my career,
>> but this is by far the worst I've ever I've ever had.
>> No, you Dude, who betrayed him here. You I don't know
who betrayed him. Okay, bro. It's like I'm sorry. Nobody betrayed
you here. You're just making a huge deal out of something that's
like embarrassing at worst. This guy said he [__]
your girlfriend, then he talked.
Now, you didn't handle it well. Your reaction was embarrassing
for you. And that's what makes you feel like betrayed is you
were embarrassed. But guess what? That's what your entire orbit
is about. That's what the entire CX universe is around. It revolves
around is embarrassing happening to people. It just happened
to you this time. And trust me, one out of 10,000 times that
somebody gets embarrassed at happening to you, that's way better
than Darius. Darius is like a 100 out of 10,000 times. Okay?
The Burger Planet guy, that's like 500 out of 10,000 times. All
the other people get embarrassed way more than you do. That's
the currency your universe runs on is humiliating each other.
It happened to you one time. You're acting like it's the end
of the world. Fire up the stream. Go live. Run the end of the
scavenger hunt. Collect your million dollars you're going to
make over the week and a half you're doing this. And stop pretending
that you're a victim. Okay. Thank you. That's all. It's it's
I mean,
you know, he he said la he said last night or the day before
he said that he decided to do this because I'm such an [__]
and oh, I'm egoing people and blah blah blah. No, it's banter.
It's that's Lav who said that. Lav has been saying that. Where
did Goon say it? Lab said it >> content. You are a giant
who can't handle the banter in the content. You are jealous that
you're poor and now you live off your wife's only fans for money.
You're a leech.
You've done nothing in this life that you can be proud of. You're
30 years old, 28, however old you are. I don't even know. This
is like this just a script for like how to talk. It's like it
doesn't even make sense. Like it makes no sense to me at all.
Ice ironically believes Goon should be able to quiet his woman
down. Uh yeah. No, that is that is okay. Yeah,
dude. I I don't know what to say. Like dude, original insult.
It just like like this is the weakest. You took a whole day off
to figure out the script for what to say when you come back and
you are doing the worst talk. That's the most embarrassing thing
here. You actually look like you aren't a streamer. I've seen
Ice Beside. He's funny. He knows how to do content. He's just
like raging and like there's nothing funny happening here. You're
just like raging out on these people, right? make a funny joke
is like nothing nothing useful. You you took a whole day off.
You didn't figure out a single funny joke to make back. >> You're
late 20s.
You've never done anything that you that you can be proud of
in this world. You you live off your wife's only fans who sucked
a dog's p.
So, I mean, you can say Lav literally advertises her only fans
as the girl who sucked her dog's p. Why are you promoting her
only fans right now? Is that the best you got, bro? I could never
mind. I could do a lot better. Okay, I could. But I won't. I'm
not going to. I don't know why. This is like the worst talk.
This is the worst trash talk. This is not going to upset anybody
at all. >> Say it's cuz I egoed you. You could say that's
the reason, but I have done more for people in the streaming
industry.
I have done more than any other streamer in this entire industry.
I have gone out of my way to help people without any gain for
myself. >> Okay, that that's where the cope comes in, right?
That you could you could even argue that he does a lot for people,
that he does a lot for the streaming community on kick, right?
I think that's true. I think that's objectively true. He does
way more than any other streamer who's got a big contract like
he has. Okay, he helps a ton and he is a super positive force
for kick. But then he adds that last part in with no benefit
to myself. Shut the [__] up. Okay, you restarted
your career. You are retiring off of your income from kick. Shut
up. Okay, shut up.
That's insane to say you're not making anything off of this.
You are helping kick. You're building a community, but you're
also making millions of dollars. So, please stop pretending,
oh, there's no benefit to myself. No. This whole thing, you've
had 10,000 viewers at least every single time you go live. You
10,000 10,000 10,000 for like six, eight, 10 hour streams. I
know you're making insane money, bro. You're making like what?
40, 50,
up to 100 grand a stream.
Don't pretend otherwise. You're making insane money. You're making
insane bank
and you couldn't handle the fact that you are just poor and you're
jealous that you're just you're just
translates to roughly the loosest translation is about a dollar
per hour per uh sorry about a dollar per hour per 10 viewers,
right? Is that what it is? I think that's about it. So, 10,000
viewers. That's like $1,000 an hour. Eight hours. Oh, did I add
in a zero? I might have added a zero. He is making like eight.
He's making probably at least 10 grand a stream. Sorry. I might
have added a zero there.
>> that you're poor and you just had to throw this at me.
>> Then he probably makes a lot more money. If you just
would have told me, I would have respected that and I still would
have helped you
because >> I don't I don't think that's true. Based on
everything based on this reaction, I don't think that's true
at all. >> I would respect that you were a man and you
came to me manto man. >> Even if he told you, Lav would
have still done the same thing to you and you still would have
felt humiliated.
Even if you knew, whether or not you knew has no bearing on whether
or not you're humiliated right now. You're humiliated because
everybody's making fun of you. That would have still happened.
>> But the way you decided to do it, there is no respect.
There's no honor. You are a complete scumbag. And you can sit
here and laugh, but I will make it very I will I will make sure
that you are on Kick's [__] list. Bro,
I feel like all of the clips I've ever seen from the CX universe
before this are them being totally classless, totally honorless,
totally human beings to somebody else. That's like every clip
I've ever seen is them just being horrible people to other people.
Is it really so simple as you got your own you got a taste of
your own medicine for 2 seconds and you're losing it? There's
no way, right? There's no way you're that soft that you get a
just a tiny taste of what everybody around you deals with on
a regular basis and you're like, "No, that's too much. No, no,
that's too much. That's too much. No, I don't think so. I'm I'm
quitting." >> I will make sure that you will never be given
any opportunity ever as a streamer. And then all her all all
her little friends, all Goon's little friends, Cutebot, Jaw Millie,
all these little friends of theirs, they didn't tell me. Oh god.
Is this from today? No. Don't Don't do it. Don't do it, bro.
Bro,
>> that's [__] up. Okay. If Ice was mad about
this, if Ice was mad that they talked after, but it shouldn't
be that he was betrayed or people had lied to him. That That's
not it at all. If you want to say you're mad because these people
are your girlfriend your girlfriend's ex is
totally fine. Okay, it's cute how they can make each other laugh.
Yeah, it's not bad. It's It's so It's so up. I I hate it. Okay,
but it's also hilarious. >> No one decided to man up. Everyone's
a coward. It is unbelievable.
But it's okay. These people live in glass houses. >> Like
put like offsetting these two things. Yeah, the vibes are just
like disastrous for Ice Boseidon in this. It's disastrous when
you like they're joking around. They I think they fully believe
that they will get off of the platform that they'll get like
kicked off the platform. They won't have any money here and they're
just like whatever. Might as well enjoy it. Might as well have
some fun. >> And these people are all very very
>> brother, brother, hold on. I I just need I just need
Hold on. Hold on. I need Yeah, this will work. This will do it.
This will do it. Can I get Can I get this over like here? Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Boom. Yeah. That's We need We need one of these for
ice besides stat. Okay. Ice, I prescribe you with a mirror, my
>> But it's okay. These people live in glass houses. And
these people are all very very insecure.
>> And and evil. >> Spider-Man pointing at Spider-Man.
>> Spiteful people. You talked about destroying all of
their careers.
Uhhuh. Oh, hold on. I just I just realized. Yes. Somebody just
Cheese Beef. That's a fantastic That's a fantastic suggestion.
Hold on. We have We have a couple choice soundtracks for this.
Okay, hold on. Hold on. Oh,
there could be a couple things, but we'll go with um this one.
Okay, this is the one. >> All Goons Little Friends. Cutebot
Jaw
All these little friends of theirs. They didn't tell me. No one
decided to man up. Everyone's a coward. It is unfucking believable.
But it's okay. These people live in glass houses. And these people
are all very very insecure
and and and evil,
spiteful people. I could sit here and say many things that I
know, secrets that I know about
Cubot. >> I've seen a couple people say this so far. He's
reading off screen. Yeah. I hope he didn't write anything down.
That would make this so much worse. Okay, if this isn't just
scattered like like sad >> at all their little friend group
there,
but it's just unnecessary. I gained nothing from it. I don't
need to do I don't need to stoop down to their level.
>> Oh, hello.
>> Not a mistake for the gifted >> as much as I want
to. I just I just can't believe it. I can't believe Kimberly.
I can't believe I just can't believe
all those streamers. I just can't believe it. >> You win.
>> Oh, hold on. What's this? Anonymous. Another gifted
sub. Thank you very much.
>> And I'm not going to let these
toxic people consume me. I'm When this scavenger hunt finishes,
I'm just going to take time to myself,
self-reflect, build myself up, and just learn from it. That's
all I can do. There's nothing else I can do. So,
they'll sit there, they'll continue their toxic existence. I'll
build myself up and self-reflect. And then >> you going
to cry. He's He's emotional. This is why, okay, sometimes it's
good to take time off streaming. Okay, you feel really emotional,
just take time off streaming. It's totally fine. >> In
the end, I'm going to live a happy, fulfilling life cuz I have
something that I can be proud of. I have things that I've built
that I can be proud of, whereas they have nothing
and they have nothing to be proud of. Aren't you taking the thing
you built and that you're proud of and like trying to crush it
right now? Aren't you describing like actually destroying that
entire legacy? Like I'm very proud of this community I built.
I'm very proud of this like community and this ecosystem I built.
Also, I'm going to totally crush it cuz somebody somebody crossed
me. Okay, somebody acted like I would have if I had that same
information. Somebody acted like, you know, everybody else in
this whole community would have and now I'm crashing the [__]
out. I'm going to blow it all up >> that they have ever
done in their life. I'm successful.
I have money. I have good friends. And I will eventually find
people that are good for me.
>> Whereas they will continue to grind doing things that
go against their own values to try to make money and still not
be proud and have nothing at >> No, they have Dude, none
of you guys have values. Just stop acting like you guys are moral
streamers. You're not. Some of you might have like some principles,
but for the most part, you just go wild. >> The end. I
remember Goon a year ago. You seemed like a cool guy. You know,
you were always talking [__] about Only Fans. You
were always, you know, saying
>> Oh, this is his narrative. Okay. This should have been
his narrative from the start. I This is the only way Ice could
have won. And maybe he's naturally falling into it here. I remember
when Gunnar was cool. I remember when Gunnar was actually cool
and he would would have never done this. Okay. He married that
Lav girl. He's just like a total loser now. Like he's actually
the wor This is the easiest narrative for people to throw it
on the internet. A whole bunch of people like eat that up because
they're just like, "Yeah, the only girl I've ever dated ruined
me, too." Right? Like it's You literally don't go
You don't go after Gunnar directly. You just say, "Oh, Gunnar's
like kind of a loser now." He kind of just lets Lav run his life.
Do you see how he like let Lav just totally totally [__]
him over and like leak all this [__] Burn all of
his connections. You see how he did that? That's what Ice could
have done if he was cutthroat. If he was not emotional right
now, he would have done that. And that would have been really
hard to pull back from. Like that would have he could have gotten
Gunnar's uh people to agree with him. He could have gotten like
right some there are some people there who probably like this
[__] sucks. I hate this [__] Right. That
would have totally worked. He could have totally he could have
totally gone with that. But instead, he went with this. I'm betrayed.
I've never been to I don't know how I'll ever trust anybody again.
I I I
help all these people so much and they won't help me at all.
>> Iden, you know, is you know, I love that all the vents
that you do. I love this and that. Like you you seemed like a
cool guy and then you married this chick Lav and she has changed
you for the absolute worst. >> Oh, okay. He's getting it.
He's getting it. He's getting it. Let's go. You you now do Only
Fans something that went against your values
and instead of trying to work for your own money. >> Oh,
hello. Hello. >> Anonymous. Thank you for the gifted sub.
>> Which is what? >> Thank you. Thank you. >> Which
is what you wanted to do in the past, you've now decided to just
be a leech
off your girlfriend's only fans.
There's nothing to be proud of there. You married this chick
last. I remember. >> You're right. You're right. You're
right. You're right. Um, hold on. I need uh I need different
music. Hold on. Give me a second. Give me a second. What's the
What's the This the one? Yes. >> Goon a year ago. You seemed
like a cool guy. You know, you were always talking [__]
about Only Fans. You were always, you know, saying >> he's
he's entered the the mind. Okay. He's entered the mind. >> Events
that you do. I love this and that. Like you you seemed like a
cool guy. And then you married this chick Lav and she has changed
you for the absolute worst. You ch you you now do Only Fans,
something that went against your values. And instead of trying
to work for your own money, which is what you which is what you
wanted to do in the past, you've now decided to just be a leech
off your girlfriend's Only Fans.
There's nothing to be proud of there. >> The Only Fans
[__] ruined him completely. That's he's found the
narrative. Okay, this one This one would work. I don't like that
he went the other way to begin with. This one will work. He can
he can work this one in. Okay. A lot of people will buy this
>> I don't know what else to say.
>> And Cupbot, uh, I know that you have a lot of secrets
and a lot of insecurities. Not >> I think Cupbot leaked
some DMs. I think that's what he's
>> secrets and insecurities. >> Pretty sure Kiana
leaked. You should
really question who you're friends with and question your own
personality
deep within on keeping secrets.
>> I mean, I just don't know what else to say. I'm just
so
I'm just so flabbergasted and just
completely
up right now and like totally deflated.
Like so much anger is just festering through my soul and I just
don't I just don't know what I'm supposed to do. >> That's
a total Darius line. Tell me that's not a total Darius line.
There's so much anger festering in my soul right now. Uh he all
he needs to do Okay, he's a little too but he needs to put his
hand over his nose, right? You know, you put you the tips of
your finger on your nose while you hold your hand there. Will
you like tilt your head and look at the camera? There's so much
anger festering inside of my soul. you know, just stooping down
to their level isn't going to make me feel better. It's only
going to make me feel worse. Obviously, I can't let them uh I
can't let these people win. You know, I I'm going to continue
the event. And uh I'm eventually going to feel better about myself,
but it's going to take a while. I'm only human. I'm not a robot.
I figured everything out at the worst possible way imaginable
on camera in public in front of everybody. And I think that I
am a fighter. I'm a pretty strong person. And I think that I'm
handling this the best that I think anybody would be able to
handle this. >> I'm not crying. I'm not sad. I'm just angry.
I'm very angry. >> You're also very sad. I Come on. You're
also very sad. >> It's crazy that I'm not sad,
but I How could I mean, how can I be sad? I've I've I've been
over it. There's nothing to be sad about. There's only anger.
>> God, such a good song. >> If you as the viewers
want to help me through this, >> hold on. The best thing
that you can do >> Hold on. We got a vibe switch coming.
>> If you as the viewers want to help me through this,
the best thing that you can do is just ignore these people. Let
them just fade off into irrelevancy. That is the best thing you
can do. Because what they want is for people to go into their
streams. Even if you're talking about them, that's what they
want. The best thing you can do is just let them fade into irrelevancy
and just let me handle it behind the scenes to make sure these
people never have any opportunities given to them ever. Thank
you for the 25 subs.
Sesh.
Oh, speaking of guys, if you like the content, if you're a fan
of the stream, okay, you can make the content go for longer.
We are currently something like six subs away from another hour
on the stream. All right, sorry, another two hours on the stream.
Okay, so guys, gift subs TTS exclamation point donate in the
chat. We'll give you the TTS links. I'll pin one of those right
now for you, the Kickbot link. Okay, you can donate through Kickbot.
You can donate through Streamlabs. You can sub on kick. You can
go over the Twitch twitch.tv/JK
with an underscore and you can you can give me a prime there.
If you got Twitch primes, throw me Twitch primes. Really appreciate
Twitch primes. Okay, so guys, give subs. Uh individually sub
if you can. If you have an individual sub available to you, go
ahead, individually sub. that gives me recurring income every
single month that I can plan my budget around. Okay, thank you
guys so much for all the support. Last but not least, there's
a Patreon. patreon.com/jastk.
If you join the Patreon, there's perks in the Discord. All right,
join the community. discord.gg/jdk
as well for most of those perks. It's extra content. There's
all kinds of things. All right, guys. Thank you very much. That's
the shill, okay? The 2-hour update, the 2-hour shill. Please
get the subs in so we don't have to shill later in the stream.
All right, let's get all the hours added up early. All right,
I trust you. I believe in you guys. Thank you very much for listening
to me. All right, let's continue on. >> And I still have
so much to handle as well. Like, when this is all over, I have
so much to handle in my personal life. I I don't know what what
I'm even going to do. >> Oh, are we entering sad boy mode?
It's so much to handle in his personal life. Okay, I'm going
to try one more. We'll see if this works. Okay, we'll see if
this works. >> I just don't I don't know if you I don't
know how if you guys can even understand how I feel. You win
the point, >> you know.
>> Uh, thank you very much for the gifted sub anonymous.
Appreciate >> you have love when you love somebody and
>> Zool9 over on Twitch with the Twitch primer. I really
appreciate it. >> Ice is going to open a bar in a little
town called Springfield, USA. Where is that town? Where is that
town exactly?
Thank you guys very much for the subs, the Twitch primer, the
gifted sub. Appreciate it. Appreciate it. I just don't I don't
know if you I don't know how if you guys can even understand
how I feel. You know, when you have love when you love somebody
and then you just get completely over and you just learn the
absolute worst information that love turns into anger and hate.
My love is is now hate. It's hatred. It's not love anymore. It's
hatred. Then hate and love is very close to very close together
in feelings. And then when I ask what's going on, the only response
that I get is that I never lied to you. I'm not lying. And I'm
and I just have to question and say, "What the are you talking
about? You you just can't even be honest with me. All you can
say is that you never lied." That is the most insane gaslight
I've ever heard in my life. And I I just can't believe it. Everybody
in my Discord is like, "Oh yeah, you should just uh find another
find other another girl. Find blah blah." I don't want to find
any girl. I don't want any woman in my life. I just need to be
alone. I want to be alone.
>> and just focus on myself. I don't want any woman in
my life. I don't want any girls messaging me trying to slide
in my DMs, trying to whatever. I don't want that. I don't want
to talk to you. >> I don't want to talk to any woman. >> Women
stay away. Okay. Stay away. Do not >> I just don't trust
anybody. And I just want to focus myself. >> Nah. Nah,
nah, nah, nah. The carnival music doesn't work. Doesn't work
for this. No, no, no, no, no. >> You know, and it's it's
like I don't hate women. I don't have disdain for women. I'm
not that's not the energy that I'm bringing. I just would rather
be alone. >> I function much better on my own. Okay. Outside
of relationships,
>> I don't even want to talk to any of my
>> I just don't trust anybody >> at this point. I
don't want to talk to any I don't want to talk to anybody. I
just I I just I just want to f I just I don't know. I just don't
I I don't want anybody around me. I'm going to sit here, continue
the event, give money away,
do all do all of that, and just try to keep a happy face
and good energy during it, >> which is the hardest thing
I've ever had to do >> considering I don't know how much
longer this is going to go. >> At least Tazo's crushing
it, right? At least Tazo's crushing it. Making the event end
really early. You adding the music? I am.
Like I really I really wish that I could just not be live right
now. Trust me, I really do. >> Said it might take weeks.
They're at They're at clue 45 or they're on clue 46 out of 50.
How many more weeks could we possibly take? >> But yeah,
I mean that's all right. That's it. I mean, I don't really have
anything else to say. That's pretty much it. I mean, just like
everything in my soul, you know, wants to go down this evil route
and be evil, but I I just can't do that. It's just not worth
my time and it's just going to
>> continue, you know, these people will continue staying
in my life the longer I do that and I just don't want any of
these people in my life. And then Sam Pepper, you know, he's,
you know, using it for content, typing in Goons chat to leak
and all this other [__] Sam, another person that
I've helped and given opportunity to on kick, even though he
defended me on his stream,
I can see right through it. His defense of me is a very, very
vain,
superficial thing, and I'm clearly very hurt right now. And people
using this for content, it's just, you know,
>> it's very hurtful. >> Well, we don't know. I don't
have any personal relationship with you. I'm just out here grinding,
bro. Can't hate on me. I'm Dude, you can't hate on I'm just making
content, okay? What the [__] We don't have any personal
relationship. I don't know you. >> I understand it, but
it's very hurtful. You know, when Action Man
was having his drama and issues with Nick White a couple days
ago, I didn't really comment on it. I said, "There's no way this
is this is real. I don't believe it." I tried my best to, you
know, I I didn't comment on it because and issues with Nick White
a couple days ago. I didn't really comment on it. I said
there's no way this is this is real. I don't believe it. I tried
my best to, you know, I I didn't comment on it because >> Nick
White Jamie Action Man's girlfriend. What? What? No. It's not
my place and it's a very sensitive very sensitive topic. >> No,
you protected like your friend in a way you would never protected
anyone else, especially Gunnar in this space, >> But other
people, you know, don't seem to do that with me. So that's I
understand it, but it's just disgusting.
>> Hold on. Didn't Nick White fight her? I don't know.
I don't know the situation
>> months ago.
That is rough. I can't imagine having to stream through [__]
like this. This is uh this is actually like in a human way like
I could totally feel that he is like mentally up when he's silent
like this. Okay. Sometimes when he talks, I'm like, dude, this
is weird to verbalize these things. But when he's silent, you
can see it. Okay. Looks like there's some pain behind that those
eyes, brother. I think I'd see some pain behind those eyes. Just
stop talking about cancelling people and you're fine. I haven't
seen all of that. Jaw gun arc. Not seen that yet. >> I'm
just like I'm just human. >> We'll be looking into it.
He's so human. He's so real. So human. So real. >> It's
tough. And I don't need anybody to feel bad for me. I don't expect
that. I don't want that. I don't need your pity. I just don't
know what else to say. I'm
>> I'm just I don't I don't want to vent. I just want to
deal with it myself internally. That's how I've always done it
growing up. You know, I didn't have people to talk to growing
up. I just everything about the deal with it >> Yes, I'm
>> just going to do that with this. >> Take all of
your emotions. >> Not Kui Diddy. Just tip $5.
Unban Kuy Diddy. He won't talk about hockey again.
>> Who is this? Slash user Qui Diddy. Who this? Okay. You're
unbanned. Oh, it wouldn't let me unban you. What?
>> It's not letting me un unban you. Or maybe you are unbanned.
Okay. No, it's >> Be a very You're good. You're good. >> In
indifferent kind of person, and I may not be like
the most empathetic or, you know, good-hearted person in the
world, but I do my best to to try to help >> Uh, we're
going to we're actually take some time here and go to the uh
we're going to go watch this whole thing. Okay. We're gonna watch
him take some time to uh to help people. Okay. We're gonna watch
him take some time to just help people out. All the help he provided
over here. Okay, I think this actually cuts in too late into
the dinner to be honest with you. I think there's more to the
beginning of this starting with Ice during
We'll see if I can find it. Hold on. Ice Boseidon Thanksgiving.
We'll see if I can find any other videos of it. Okay.
7:41 7:45
11 minutes. No, no, there isn't a better video. This is the best
video. Okay,
we'll finish his stuff and then we'll check it out. >> Game,
you know, >> he just always tries to help people out, guys.
He never he never like uses people's relationships or like their
interpersonal dynamics against them. He's never done that. >> I'm
not a good I mean I'm not a good person, you know. I'm uh >> you
know I have everything that I do is for my own benefit in this
world
>> Oh, where was this before? >> Very selfish and
self-centered, but I'm honest about it. >> No, you Hold
on. No, no, no. The entire first 30 minutes of this was you lying
about it. What if he opened up like this and said, "Yeah, like
feels up that I put in this effort that helps everybody. Yeah,
it helps me most, but it also helps other people. Nobody else
helps anyone else. Like I'm I'm like 90% for me, 10% for others.
Everyone else is 100% for them." Right? If he said that, if he
was honest about it, then it would be fine. But he was lying
this whole time up until now, saying, "I do everything for other
people with no benefit to myself." That's verbatim what he said.
So, you know, I definitely do my fair share of bad things, but
there are certain lines that I just don't cross.
>> What are those? >> And I can at least be honest
about about what I do. That's that's not good. These other people,
they just can't be honest. Nobody's honest. >> Hold on.
Go ahead. Pirates offer. Be honest about what you do. That's
bad. >> Be honest. No hypotheticals. No. Oh, I I do bad
things. Say what you did that's >> You know, I don't know.
Yeah. You know, people could say it's karma for me. Sure, maybe
maybe it's karma. Maybe I have gotten karma for bad things that
I've done in this world, but I've also done a lot of good things,
too.
And I would hope that uh you know, people would at least respect
that, but they don't. Nobody respects it. >> Like, I don't
even I don't even totally disagree that he's done really good
things. Okay. But like
uh the bad things like the bad things don't come down to interpersonal
dynamics. The bad things would be like the crypto rugpole. um
you know selling gambling to people. These would be the bad things
that you've done, right? And I do think that gambling thing is
really easy to ignore. And I I hate to talk about it on like
this platform sometimes, but like it's really bad. It's really
really bad. It is foundationally built on financially ruining
people completely. Okay? It's not casinos and aren't financially
built on having people gamble responsibly. Okay? As much as they
do the ads and all that, that's not what they're built on. >> So
I'll just be alone and deal with it
And I I tried to I tried to just get some closure and and some
some information last night, which is why I couldn't sleep for
40 hours. I just wanted closure. I just wanted information as
to what the was going on. And I never got it. I just got I just
got gaslights. That's all I got. I got no closure. I got no honesty.
>> Just gaslights.
>> Oh jeez.
Dude, the silence is so good with the music. Thank you, Ice.
Thank you, Ice. >> Okay. Well, uh I mean, let's let's go
to the uh to the sc >> everywhere. Dingling us everywhere.
Everywhere. Literally everywhere.
Okay. L everywhere. >> Scavenger hunt then. >> Okay.
He's ready to go for the scavenger hunt. I'm guessing there will
be more comments throughout the day, guys. Now, at some point
before and during this, Kimmy also started talking about stuff
in Discord. Okay, I got a whole bunch of Kimmy Discord logs here.
Let's check them out. Grab your popcorn, boys.
Okay, I guess I have to go live then. Oh, Gunnar. Oh, I forgot
to look for Gonar's logs. Hold on one second. I believe Goer
was talking some in the chat as well. Give me a second. Let me
go find these. Wait, hold on. Kick goon
ice Poseidon. Go to
today and do back here. Okay. Yes. Search. I'm searching for
Goon's logs. Damn, he typed a lot in here.
Uh-oh. Oh, this is what Ice referred to earlier. I was not paying
enough
Uh, but I wanted to do Hunger Games based big streamers girlfriends
shouldn't [__] your interviewer Andes. I'm 26. So
when he was when Ice was saying he was 30, he says I'm 26. Ice.
That's live typing. Back to my real Nick White didn't tell you
about your girlfriend. the action man's girlfriend. My massage
agent wife destroyed you. If it makes you feel any better, I
wish I could un Kimmy, too. You get humbled, regain, and move
forward. I saved you a lot of trouble from marrying Kimmy in
time. Marrying I guess Kimmy is a muted word in his chat. In
time, you'll be grateful for that. At least
uh Goon's making it worse for himself. This didn't have to Ice
could have not been angry after this. I'm just saying Ice could
have gone, you know what? It's mostly Lav that leaked it. And
and realistically, I can't be that mad at Gunnar, but Gunnar
is making sure that that is not possible. Okay,
there's no out for Gunnar in this where he can now like come
back with all with him going and directly talking. There's no
out right
now. He's like actually dancing in this guy's grave.
There's no like, oh well, I didn't really want to hurt you that
badly. Oh, [__] me, I guess. Right. You You could
let this guy cool off. You could go You could do one of two things.
Either you really think this guy's coming for your career. really
think he can do that? And so you go and you just like on his
ashes. Okay, you just torched him. You go on his ashes.
>> Anonymous. Thank for the gifted sub. Or you could say,
"This guy's emotional right now. I'm going to let him be for
a little bit." And I think he'll come to his senses. And you're
making sure he does not have that option with these logs, right?
Maybe cheese beef. We'll see. We are going to have to go to their
after the Kimmy logs. We will be going to their stream as well.
Okay. So, let's go. These are bottom to top. We'll read these.
Okay. He messaged me and I was responding to everyone. So, this
is the log we read from before where Kimmy was saying um that
she her nose job was [__] up. So, that somebody's
I guess making fun of her for responding.
Okay, I guess I have to go live then. I wasn't the one who lied.
They lied to me. Kimmy leaves a big message. This is the most
twisted up thing I've ever been a part of. Lav is the most insecure
woman I've ever met and for no good reason. She's pretty. She
needs to just move on. I don't know what goes on in their relationship
if I've somehow been made to be a threat, but I'm not. They're
they're jealous and insecure and they have to bring me and Paul
down and embarrass us because their lives are already embarrassing
and they're miserable together. They live off of Lav's only fan
savings money. They live with Gunnar's parents and he gambles
away thousands of dollars to the point she went to the psych
ward. She came out and he kept gambling. Uh when they first met,
she was married to a nice man and opened her marriage so she
didn't have to deal with the guilt of cheating on her husband
so she could [__] Gunnar and Destiny. Uh, she mistreats
every person she's had in her life. She has no friends and everyone
hates her. Even her animals she abuses. When she moved out, this
is uh all of the Lavloon Snark. They've been on the Lavloon Snark
subreddit as well. When she moved out of LA with her previous
husband to move in with Gooner, she abandoned her cat at an Airbnb
for a month until Palm B went and rescued it. She has no care
for any life other than her own. She is completely miserable
and has a very weird obsession with me. I've never been anything
but nice to her, even previously reaching out to her when she
was being dragged public. dragged publicly when she was exposed
in the past for being a bad person during the Hassan drama. I
never had anything against her. I have no idea why the amount
of hate she has. Why she has the amount of hate she has. Uh I
think it's because I must be a recurring topic in their home
and I was told by friends even his mom brought me up at their
wedding saying how sweet I was and how I should have been there.
Okay. I live completely rentree in their heads and they need
to move on. If they're so happily married then please be it.
Okay. Second divorce is her response to something here. I don't
know what it is. Girls shouldn't cheat on their husbands. That's
who you married. An only fans girl who is married and when you
meet met her and cheated on her husband to date him. I think
they open their marriage. I mean it's it's but they open their
marriage. Not a good idea, but they did it. Live told us they
were very happy every 10 minutes on stream. Okay. They I I've
said it's like hot and cold. I can see how hot and cold it is
where they're like totally in love and then or sorry probably
also but totally in love then like angry then totally in love
then angry then I can see the back and forth right I can see
it seems concerning asker hooking up with him three years ago
not currently oh dude I agree big mistake that I regret probably
not telling Ice kind of rough lab responds
Kim you could have [__] a random guy when you were
single why did you [__] oh I agree big mistake on
my part oh and I'm also reading Top to bottom instead of bottom
to top. Oh, wait. This is the right thing though. This is a bigger
Discord message. These are like the search and that's bottom
to top. And then this is this top to bottom. Bottom to top again.
And you married him. I've never had no money without ice. Oh,
sorry. I didn't even I didn't even say the live response. You
were sucking the dick of a guy who lived in a pile of trash six
hours after meeting him. And I made it you had wait a year and
a half. Damn.
You summarized the drama. No. Be here or be queer. Okay, free
fallen. Go back to the beginning of the stream. I did a summary
and then we started running through it. You can go back about
50 minutes in. I think we start. Good luck. Okay.
You married him. You married the guy who lives in trash. I never
had I never had no money without Ice. Please show the receipts.
Never happened. I've never had no money without ice. Please show
the receipts. Never happened. I mean, Ice said as much, which
kind of [__] up. Lav never had to fight. I don't
know. Lav, we never had to fight. I don't know why you have this
one-sided beef. It's weird and obsessive. Keep putting on your
blonde wig when talking [__] about me. I'm not trying
to dig lower. I already am the relationship, the number one topic
of the relationship. It's weird. I feel bad for her. Literally,
her mother at the wedding and her mother-in-law talked about
me at her wedding saying I'm so sweet and she wished I was there.
I mean, okay, I I would just want one other person to substantiate
this. I don't even need to say it's fake, but like, can we get
the friend who told you about this? You got [__]
down in the blanket nest,
dude. Uh,
bruh. Bruh,
Aon and Lav address it. Let's go. Let's go. Okay. It's sad and
it's weird. There is no reason for her to be so psycho. The important
thing is Paul and we will be fine. They're sad and jealous and
want to tear us down and it's not going to happen. I'll keep
holding back. I'll continue laying laying low and it's just insane
and sad. Of course I do. He knows that too and this hurt him
and I understand and anyone would be hurt in this situation.
I'm not the victim. Paul is. Kimmy making yourself the victim
again. And then Lav says, "We're doing it live.
We're doing it live." So they went live and they address stuff
as well, which we're about to tune into. Okay, we're right there.
We're right there. We're about to tune in. Did I have anything
else in this meme album that I was going to go through? Hold
on. I I forget this one. I forget what I put in this one. I think
we went through it at the beginning. Oh, right. So, this is from
Was this This is from Cutebot.
So, in her message response, she said that Gunnar never responded
to my last message because he was lying about him being the reason
that you guys didn't want me to move back in and that he was
just an excuse and you guys were the ones who didn't want me
there. Is that true? It's okay. You can tell me. Sorry if that
message doesn't make sense. I tried to keep it short and I can
explain more if it's confusing. And then Kiana didn't send this,
but she types this out, I guess. Um, Gunner said Lav was scared
of Sam Pepper.
What? So, she told you whatever she told you about Good lying
to protect him. I don't really know what's going on, but we all
agreed to not have you move in cuz you were hooking up with Gunnar
and since you were with Ice and you weren't in the best spot
emotionally. It seemed like it was going to be drama, but it's
true. It wasn't his only his decision and we all had to come
to an agreement, but we had him take the fall. Sorry for making
you worry. We decided this so that you would feel least hurt,
but I guess that it didn't work out anyway. No one hates you
either. Oh, so they did they did actually decide as a group that
they weren't going to let Kimmy move in. No, I don't think Kimmy
cheated on Ice. Sounds like explicitly she was talking about
moving back in with them and they knew that Gunnar had her. So
they were like, "You know what? No, that's going to be drama.
You guys are together right now." Bro, Lav is either going to
divorce Goar and wreck him with child support or murder him inside
of 5 to seven years. I have a crystal ball and I know this to
be true. Okay, relieve this relationship won't work out. Turns
out 95% of the time you're just correct. So few marriages, so
few relationships stay stable for that long a period of time.
You're basically saying like, "I bet the sun will come up tomorrow."
Okay,
shut up. Holy [__] Bomb drop. She's been [__]
Go Gunnar for ages cuz you were hooking up with Goonar. No, you
used This isn't even a bomb drop. What the [__] This
isn't a bomb drop at all. They were hooking up together when
they lived together, which was years ago. Uh random quick on
the mattress is not a relationship. There was no mattress, dog.
Ice open your eyes, bro. And that's uh that's this from the from
the stream. Okay. From the beginning of the stream. It's the
blanket nest. Okay. This was on This was making $10,000 a month
and 9,000 of it was going to stake.com. Okay. He's just getting
paid back by Eddie right now. Okay. N grand going to Stake, one
grand going to rent and food. Rent and what a burger. Okay. Kimmy
let go drive Ice's Tesla. Me and Leia hadn't even met in person
when I was hooking up with Kimmy, but Kimmy was taking me to
parties where I was and had me drive his Tesla home because she
was too drunk. Keep coping, young blood. And this is Sean from
Las Vegas saying Sam has known since the last scavenger hunt.
He was uh he asked about Gunnar when D10 and Gunnar were going
to fight last scavenger hunt over the D10's child comment. LOL
the little rat trying to do amate control now because Ice is
he knew they Sam knew they I don't know why this Sean from Las
Vegas guy is saying it. I don't know what the these chat me chat
messages are with no date stamp on them but playing pipe in the
blanket for is crazy work. It really is crazy work isn't it?
It's wild, bruh. Okay, finally, last but not least, we're on
to the We're on to the Lav Gooner stream. Okay, we're going to
check out that Lav Gooner stream. We're going to see what's up
with that. And then, yeah, I don't know. I don't know where we're
going after that. I ordered some food, so I'll get some food
in as well. Probably during the stream at some point. Oh, the
Taco Ball place still has stuff on two for one. So, let's go.
Let's go. Taco Bables. Is he in a rest? We will cover that eventually.
Yes, we will get to it. We are five. Oh, what is this? We're
like three subs away. I think we're three subs away from another
two hours on the stream, guys. Get those subs in. Okay, get those
subs in. Look at my docket. Find the gunner Lav Vod. Look like
this is about when they go live.
>> We are pretty apologetic for that one. >> Uh maybe
a little too early into the stream. We'll see. >> Really
bad. >> Little too early. >> There we go.
>> They still have each other. >> Yeah, that's all
you really need. >> He's talking about Cupbot. Well, Cubot
Cubot tried to snake me. Cupbot tried to make me take my take.
>> Uh, Cupbot didn't really make him look like a liar.
Cupot was just like trying to do damage control for herself.
She's like, "Yeah, we did kind of all make this decision, but
uh it was just cuz we didn't want drama." >> Cupot and
her lie and put that over me and my wife and my integrity cuz
Kimmy was lying to people about a love letter thing. So, follow
at the end of the day, I don't need streaming. I don't give a
>> Wait, did this happen, Cheese Beef? Where's Where's
Cutebot's comments? Someone firing Cutebot's comments right >> But
we do genuinely feel bad and I understand that Ice Poseidon has
probably never had to feel these emotions before. And we are
we are pretty apologetic for that one. >> Well, he feels
these emotions if he sticks with Kimmy. >> Lav just hates
Kimmy so much. >> What do you think she >> I DM'd
you them? Oh, >> been doing that apartment in LA, buddy.
>> I didn't see that. >> It hurts now, but he'll
get over it and he'll learn from it. So, it is what it is. part
of life,
>> guys. I didn't dog. And if I did, I'd be waking I'd
be making way more money off.
>> They're uh they're in the Discord. Let's go. Hold on.
Let's check out these Kiana messages before we move forward.
Okay. Oh, I forgot this Darius Thanksgiving thing. Oh, it's a
move file. Hold on. We're getting there. We're getting there.
We're getting there. Hello. Oh, god damn it. One second. One
second. One second. I need to upload this to streamable to show
it on stream.
There we go. Cutebot stream checkbod. Are you sure? Cuz it looks
like I got a scroll here from her phone, right? I think if I'm
not mistaken. Oh [__]
This cute bot and Okay. All right. DJ. Who's DJ? Who's this?
My eyes. Hold on. Can I Can I dark mode this for you? I can dark
mode it for you. There you go. Your eyes are fine. Your eyes
are okay. You're going to make it. You're all going to be safe.
All right. Okay. All right. All right, let's let's let this play.
Let's see what we got here. We just read this, right? This Kimmy
and Oh, no. This is different. Because I was with Gunnar, but
then you guys saw then I saw you guys and you didn't hate me
and everything was fine. Then I said, "Yeah, I put Jaw and Gunnar
in, but not Malik." I don't know. I think let him. Someone that
supposedly loves you would never behave like that. Oh, what is
this from? What do we tie this to? Would this be kicker keep
her? Kicker keep. I don't even know. Lav messaged me asking if
Paul's if Paul's was going to expose anything from me and Gunnar
and I told her no. In her message response, she said that Gunnar
never responded to me last message. Oh, right, right, right,
right, right. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Okay. Oh, this is her and Jaws
messages. What the [__] Okay. Yeah. Well, Ice talked
about trying to [__] Malik, right? Like we we've
seen the clip. We've seen that clip.
Who's got the clip?
Ice made it weird for Malik, right?
Who's Who's got the clip? Hold on. Let me grab this Let me grab
this clipoop.
There it is. >> Well, believe it or not, I'm very attractive.
Um, you should know that. >> Keep telling yourself that.
Keep telling >> Keep telling yourself that. I mean, you
should know. >> What does that mean?
>> It means Malik tried to,
>> dude. Why would you do this when your girlfriend's running
this panel, dude? Anyway, sorry. They do uh they do map the crazy
face onto Kimmy here. That's crazy clip. Okay, crazy clip. Okay,
let's read this. This is John and Kiana talking to each other.
Yeah, it's a long story. One of Ice Besides friends came in my
chat trying to stir up drama with me and Kimmy and Ice and it
all spiralled to this. Ah, just blame me and Jaw. Say me and
Jaw cooked up the plan. It's your fault. Or just tell the crazy
the truth. She was going to move in with us again. Now I think
she won't want to. That's the actual story. the new drama. You
said I'm riding motorcycle right now. I'll give full context.
I in five. Okay. Well, her and Ice were fighting. Sam Pepper
comes in my chat saying, "Spill the gossip." Oh, so this must
be Gunnar, right? This is Gunnar right here. So, this is a group
chat with I think this is a group chat with Kiana, Jaw, and Goonar.
I think that's what this is. Okay, somebody correct me if I'm
wrong, but I believe that's what this is. So, and it just made
me and Leia very worried. So, she reached out to Kimmy to say
to ask what Sam Pepper knew, yada yada yada. And Leia was worried
Ice was going to tell everyone about me and Kimmy. Then Leia
was worried Kimmy was mad. Ah, that moves really fast. What the
[__] Then Leia was worried Kimmy was mad at me for
not letting her move in. So she told her the truth about why
I told her she couldn't go. Lying [__] is mad. How
do [__] lie so much and suck at suck at it so bad?
Can I just say that you li that you lied to laugh or something?
No. I'm the most honest person and best liar. Okay, Jaws. Jesus.
Just own up to it. Kimmy sucks to live with and is distracting
for you. Okay, I guess we're never talking to Kimmy again because
of Lav. We're at war now with Gunnar now. Now with Gunnar.
So this sounds like they actually do hate Kimmy. They actually
do hate living with Kimmy and they just lied. So maybe maybe
Gunnar leaked this cuz it sounds like they actually did hate
living with Kimmy. They didn't want her back, but they wanted
to maintain like clout friendships, right? That's what this sounds
like. Just tell her you were annoyed with her behavior and didn't
want to deal with it again. It's that simple. Kimmy is moving
in. I wouldn't have done that if I didn't trust you, Gunnar.
It wasn't me. You can't expect Gunnar to keep things from his
wife. Oh, Jaw with actual wisdom. Some slight actual wisdom.
This scroll moves so fast. Can I slow this down? Jesus. I wouldn't
have done that if I didn't trust you, Gunnar. Was it me? The
cho The choices between my wife and being able to clear through
some uh something personal and avoid public drama and you being
a little uncomfy behind the scenes. I'm going with my wife. It's
just that simple. I'm sorry if it puts you in a weird spot. You
guys suck.
So, she types this back as a message that she's going to send.
Leia was also scared of Ice because he was crashing out and threatening
to tell her secrets. This message is fine, but you should also
talk about how you were annoyed with her so she's aware before
moving back in just so you don't have to deal with her BPD in
the future. Is that how BPD works? I want her to move back in.
If if she isn't told she sucks directly, how can she fix it?
Scrolls back up. Is he going to click on this or something? She's
not mad about it. She's more concerned about whether I hate her
or or not. She's cute. Please don't let lump me in with we all
decided. I am an honest man.
All you have to make things difficult. You guys made it difficult
by
All you have to do is show allegiance with Kiana to make her
life easier. You're being like Kimmy. She hates you and didn't
want you or your other best friend Malik in the Hunger Games.
Kiana
Kiana can just be nice to her friends and get ones that aren't
real. Sorry. Maybe Jaw is funnier or something. Maybe maybe Jaw's
actually funnier than I thought. Actually, just tell the truth.
to stop being a
How about that? How about we just do
Let's go. Uh, I'm very nice to my friends. That's why you went
to Kimmy's birthday, right? He's like doing the Dave Beckham
thing. Be honest. Be honest. Be honest. Okay.
That's why you went to Kimmy's birthday, right? I didn't see
the invite until 3 days later. Birthday. You should have known
it was her birthday instinctively. Also, mark it on your calendar
to set alarms. Also, you should be the one inviting her to a
surprise birthday that you have been planning for months like
a real friend. I read the message Lav sent and it was so unnecessary
throwing us under the bus to make her look better. How the you
think Ice is going to ban you?
Be careful who you trust. Why are you people so afraid of ICE?
Lav is a is a hard.
Okay. Uh, it was the truth. You're just coping. You didn't want
Kimmy to move in and she always hates you or she hates you anyways.
I love Kimmy. Nah, you guys are dumb now. I don't want to trust
you with logs.
Uh, we read all of this yesterday.
I saw that already. So unnecessary. Reaching out for no reason
just to make Kimmy and me feel bad. I don't care. Do you even
Do you see how this situation was not even about you?
Truth gets you. That makes it worse. Unnecessarily bringing me
into it. Just tell Kimmy the truth and own up to it. It is seriously
not that big of a deal. Le even said in the message it was part
of a drama to begin with. I already cleared it up with her. I
already cleared it up with her. It's still unnecessary or annoying
and unnecessary. So, it's settled. Who cares? Paranoid skitsos.
What did you say to uh what did you say to Kimmy? The first message
you were sending skitso asses. Okay, you're a new roommate. Lol.
[__] you. Told Kimmy the truth. I do not care anymore
about this gay drama. Tell her the truth and you won't be annoyed
with her as a roommate. I deleted a lot of things I was going
to say because I still respect our friendship and decided not
to go nuclear. Sorry to drag this on further. just going to be
truthful with you since Kiana is not owning up to things and
is pissing me off and now oh so he's just gonna leak all the
things he was gonna say send to Kimmy. He's just leaking all
of those things. Cool. This got to be Gunnar. This is Gunnar
100%. This is He says my wife. Talk about Leia. That's Gooner.
There's a group chat of Goonar, Kiana, and Jaw. Goarbot and Jaw.
Dude, the scroll speed, the inconsistent scroll speed here. Goonar
doesn't even do drama. What are you [__] doing, bro?
All of which Leia only told her told you because you had mentioned
that I hadn't responded to your message about it months ago and
I didn't know how to respond and I'm sorry for leaving you high
and dry like that. I know Kiana wants you to move in again. Oh,
this this is what he was going to send to Kimmy. By the way,
this is what Gunnar was going to tell uh Kimmy. Wait, I said
it was Gunnar from the very beginning. I didn't know you said
it, but I said it was Gunner from the very beginning. Oh. Uh
I know Ka wants you to move in again, and I don't want to cause
any problems with that. I've obviously been completely truthful
with my wife about everything regarding our situation. There's
no bad blood. Leia was only trying to be mature and reach out
to you because we did not know what Sam Pepper was trying to
start or what he knew. And now that our now our relationship
is serious and we've moved past any uh we've moved past any past
online relationship drama, we weren't sure if we I would get
dragged into this. There's no beef anywhere. And I didn't want
her to be painted like she was lying to you or being needlessly
mean to you. She's just a straight. There's what I said. I ain't
reading all that. This was a joke on you. This is a joke.
Uh Gunnar posts the ice beside gun to the face picture. Classic.
I forgive you. That's it. That's the whole scroll of the That's
the Gooner leaks with them. Okay, that was the Gooner leaked
with them. Hold on. Do we have anything else here?
I think this is basically all of it. I think we basically got
all of it. I think this is something that I I'm not sure I got
100%. Girls shouldn't cheat on their husbands. That's who you
married. blah blah blah blah stuff you literally cheated to.
I never cheated, she says. Okay, Kimmy maintaining that she never
cheated. And last but not least,
Lab throws this one out. Kimmy also almost started in Only Fans
like 50 times and would message Tim paragraphs about how she
had no money without ice and was cutting herself in just for
Tim to be like, "No, don't. No, don't. No, don't. No, don't.
No, don't." Okay.
Okay. All right. We can finally go to the Goonar live stream.
We got We've read all the messages. Here's all the messages.
Let me back it up a little bit >> You stick to Kimmy. >> What
do you think she's been doing in that apartment in LA, buddy?
>> Yeah. It hurts now, but he'll get over it and he'll
learn from it. So, it is what it is. It's part of life.
>> Guys, I didn't a dog. And if I did, I'd be waking I'd
be making way more money on Only Fans.
>> Why are you rubbing salt in the wound? I mean, we >> Jesus
Christ, Slime, chill, bro. >> There's nothing we can do
at this point. Like, it's out there. Who cares? Let the community,
let him deal with it. Let the people involved deal with it. Like,
we don't give a [__]
>> Video proof. There's no There's a video of me kissing
my girl dog's tummy. That was a girl dog. Her vagina is nowhere
near her tummy. She's a wiener dog. Her vagina is next to her
butthole,
not on her tummy.
>> Wow. You will pay to the end for scorning our master.
Well, it wasn't me that me that >> he called you. Jesus.
>> Well, Kimmy scorned it more than I did. >> And
even then, I scorned it more than you did. He has very few reasons
to be mad at you. >> Very few. >> this is more accurate.
Gunar. >> Yeah, it's more accurate. >> At the end
of the day, I am appreciative of the events he put on. Um, but
I'm not going to be disrespected. Like, you can throw out disrespect
and you can call somebody stupid. And >> why is Gutter
acting like he made a decision here? Shut the up. You rolled
with the punches. What are you Why are you acting like you made
any decision? I'm not going to be respected disrespected like
that. You were disrespected like that. You literally took it.
You literally took it. You were going to keep taking it and L
didn't like that you were taking it. So, she said something.
Okay, that's what Push
>> Try to belittle them in front of 10,000 people. But
when the shoe's on the other foot, you the guy that been humiliating
people for years, making a living off of it, you get what's coming
to you and what goes around comes. This is true. >> That's
that >> this is that's true. That part is also >> Sorry
you couldn't handle it very well. >> Oh, why why can't
anybody just be honest about what's happened here and not cope?
Everybody does like 50% cope and then 50% honesty. Why not try
like 80% honesty, 20% cope, okay?
>> Just be better. >> Your career is done. I don't
care about my stream. And that's the thing. Like he thinks that
I did it for view count. He thinks I did it for clout. I didn't.
I came to the event for money and to compete in a competition
and the competition was scuffed because he doesn't know how to
run and he's a that's that nothing they can do. >> You
didn't do it. You didn't do it. You told your wife this a long
time ago. She obviously knew a month ago, right? Unless you're
going to say, "Well, I told Lab to do this." Is that what you're
going to say? Are you going to come out and say, "I actually
planned this with Lab and I told her to do it." I bet. Oh, man.
Uh I feel like I feel like they could come out to like maintain
the image kind of. They could do something like
I gave her permission to do it. I don't know. I don't know, >> To
cope their way out of it. I came. I saw. I conquered. >> You
came. >> I came. I came. I came. I came. I saw. And I conquered.
It is what it is. You're welcome.
>> You sound jealous. Like guys, there's no amount of jealousy
like I've met rich people. I've met poor people. I much prefer
poor people. Money doesn't change who you are deep down in your
heart. You can throw a billion dollars at a scumbag, there's
still going to be a scumbag. Like, it's up to personal >> My
nose is crooked. >> What did you gain from this? Freedom.
>> I don't have to stream anymore. And I don't give a [__]
>> bro. Why don't these people with their in dramas, why
don't they like think about the things they're going to say before
they go live? Like, why not have like some interesting or funny
things to say? That's all. Just like, yeah, give me anything.
I gained freedom. Why don't you just say like I I didn't gain
anything. I should like it's like a principle. This guy's talking
[__] I was going to let him now now that he has talked
[__] and now that she leaked that that we'd like
I'm going to talk [__] now. [__] you.
They're the type to think about what they're going to say. They
would there would be no drama to begin with. Not true. You don't
think Lav was workshopping half of those things when she like
imagined this in the shower like that she was going to have this
confrontation with Ice or whoever? You don't think Lav cooks
these things up in a cauldron for like weeks and months knowing
that she's going to release them at the exact right moment?
You are you kidding me? You kidding me? >> Well, now that
it's out there because Kimmy was lying about me to a bunch of
other people and saying that I was obsessed with her, trying
to belittle me behind the scenes and >> Ice Poseidon just
said that today too >> Yeah, he's still running with that
lie that I was obsessed >> because he wants to get back
with her. >> Yeah, he's he's trying desperately to >> he's
Yeah, he's uh >> Yeah. So, save your boy. Save your boy.
Don't worry about me and what I'm doing. save your boy cuz he's
so he's like three month vacation away from like falling for
her again and she's just going to do the same thing over and
over again. Like learn your lesson, dude. You got humbled. Learn
your lesson. Move forward. I just don't get I I still don't understand.
You got humbled. He kind of got humbled, but like I don't get
what she I still don't get what she did wrong here. Like unless
she explicitly lied somehow. Like he said, "I want to know the
whole truth about you and Gunnar. Tell me everything. Tell me
exactly what happened." and she was like, "Here's exactly what
happened." She has the right to say no to that question as well,
but if she said, "This is exactly what happened." If she left
things out, then that would be bad. That was like the only That's
the only way I can imagine her being faulted here >> and
find a new >> You got humbled. Quit streaming.
Yeah, you got humbled. Quit streaming. >> Woman, scoop
up a 22year-old and call it a life. Retire. That's all you got
to do. All right, >> my food just got here. Just give me
a second, guys. I'm actually starving. I need this food. Give
me two seconds.
We're still watching. >> Feastiality is illegal. >> I
knew from the beginning your woman was going to ruin this for
you. >> What did she ruin the 12 hours that I stream every
month? I don't give a [__] I don't care.
Stop saying you are buying into the idea that that >> feel
like that's the thing. I don't care if I lose it. I don't care
if I get banned. I don't care if I lose my money >> I'll
I'll go I'll go take a look. I I feel like he streams more than
that. >> I don't need this. >> Yes. You're also buying
into the idea that that's going to happen. It's not going to
happen. >> It would be a terrible if >> you never
Yes, but also you never relied on the CX audience.
>> yeah, you you guys I came to the CX >> made you
more than I was. Cubot made me more than I >> sprinting
on a treadmill, breathing as heavy as I can just so there's less
air on the planet. Earth for lav haters. That is that's an energy
that is missing in this chat and I appreciate it. Okay, Mark
Carney, thank you. Thank you for throwing that out there. All
right, that's that's a wild comment, but it is funny. Okay, thank
you for that comment. Uh, good streamed 100 hours this month.
But I guess I guess it's mostly this. Yeah, okay. It's mostly
this. So before that, he was doing Oh, man. Could you see? We
go to his all streams. Can we see how many hours he was doing?
Go like airtime. He did have a The last month's not been good.
Before that, May, June, he was streaming a lot. I guess he just
takes time off between his events. like he wants to do the ice
beside events and then he takes time off streaming. That seems
to be more what it was. I got it. I got it. >> And the
only reason I dragged her into this is because she was talking
about me like I was her pet. >> Weirdo. Turbo weirdo mode.
>> She was claiming ownership over me.
Like holy narcissism moment. >> I don't have beef. I hope
everyone stays friends. I hope that I really want >> Come
on. I don't have beef. I just, bro, this whole thing started
because you hate Kimmy.
I don't think I don't know how much of it is insecurity, but
Lab does like hate Kimmy. Like, deeply hates Kimmy. Apparently,
they addressed the wedding comments >> to come out Chicago.
>> I I don't think
John, everyone to come out to Chicago. >> Well, here's
the room. >> I don't think this I don't think we could
we could come back from this ever. There's no like bridges that
have been crazily burned.
>> Yeah, get she's being very weird. like to go live when
you're on a different platform, not involved in the situation.
I wonder who might have like put her up to that socially. H maybe
the woman that we warned you all about. >> Wait, do we
have to go to the Kiana stream? I didn't even know. We might
have to go check out the Kiana stream, guys. I'm sorry. What
did Kiana say in her stream?
Hello. I'm back. Did you miss me? >> Hold on.
Was this actually This is yesterday. Hold on. Is this the stream
where she talks about it?
Did you >> or did she delete a stream? >> I could
go >> cuz I could see her deleting a stream. >> Give
me a second. >> I'm doing better as this puppy, but I'm
>> I'm looking. I'm looking. I'm looking. >> Not
doing so well overall. >> We'll find it.
>> Cute. Cute.
>> Dang it. I missed it.
>> Oh yeah, there's a stream from today.
>> Yay. We got it. We got it. There's >> although
what the hell? >> So now we're going into Marvel Rivals.
I'm gonna use the bathroom and I'll be back in a second. Hello.
Hello. I'm back. Did you miss me?
Oh, featured. Wait, I'm scared cuz I don't know what's happening.
I'm scared. >> Okay, hold on. We got this stream from
>> Shut up. >> But I don't know if she >> some
more.
Let's play some >> talks about this. Let's go play some
>> Let's play. Let's play. Let's play. I back.
Okay. And now I'm going to Let's open up. >> What did she
talk about? We need clips. Does anybody have the tea on this?
>> Yellow rifles action.
>> New skins. Another uh another great stream I got to
watch.
>> Reading the art of war. I don't see anything getting
leaked here. >> You have to understand your enemies better
than they understand themselves. So, you're able to predict their
moves. >> Scanning. Scanning. Scanning.
>> Know what I mean? Yeah, I'm not seeing anything. It's
just a Marvel rival stream the whole time. >> Oh, the greatest
war general. >> Please move the ice beside chair. No, you
guys. That ice besidon chair is placed tactically to prevent
gooning. It's an anti-gooning ice beside chair.
There were clips posted around. I thought I saw clips, too, but
I don't know if I Hold on. I'll check out I'll check out CX Discord.
Yeah,
we want to goon. No, stop. No gooning. Do not goon. Do not goon.
Okay, we'll figure it out later. We'll figure if it's important,
we'll go back. We'll fill this in, right? If it's important,
we'll go back.
>> I assume she went live and said something to try to
rebuild her bridge with Kimmy and then that's why Gunnar leaked
all of his DMs, right? >> Alan Sha down here, Daisy aka
Cubot's dog, and then all the women. Maybe Charlie's up there
with the dog, but the dog. No, I'm up there with the dog with
the door closed.
Well, we hope you guys enjoy the scavenger hunt. I'm sure it
continues. >> We don't need the ice chair anymore. Not
>> Do is just regain and move forward. There's no there's
no point in crying and component about it. It sucks. Move on.
Do your thing. >> He's annoying. How do you deal with her?
>> He's handling it a lot better than I would to be honest.
I would have uh I would have switched to a mobile IRL setup and
done something very crazy if that happened to me publicly in
front of 10,000 people. >> I don't think so. I I actually
don't think that you would. I think you would >> like the
end of Sons of Anarchy with five stars on GTA. >> You would
just never be with someone like that. There are certain things
that you have to >> Did she Did she not see the irony in
what she just said? That the whole drama started because he was
with somebody like that specifically that somebody would just
never be with somebody like uh what? Pardon me?
Partardo pard pardon?
Ma'am, what are you saying? when you
value he obviously doesn't value women with integrity with a
brain so you have to there's some drawback like >> yeah
he made his bet >> yeah if you value people who are transparent
intellectual
people know like those sort of people know to not do that to
they know how to avoid certain ways to not humiliate their boyfriend
>> why why do people in like the Twitch politics sphere
say wallet when referring to rich wallet I just I like have but
like come on man. Come on man. What are you saying? >> People
know like those sort of people know to not do that to they know
how to avoid certain ways to not humiliate their boyfriend >> of
nine years >> of nine years. To be fair though like maybe
he kind of deserves it cuz you wasted nine years of her life
without a >> Yeah. Like no there's no winners on this side
of that. >> That's what I'm saying. Like >> nine
years of your life would wash down the drain just for this to
happen. That's what like honestly like you maybe you deserve
it for wasting a decade of her life without marrying her and
giving her a baby. >> that's gnarly. >> I sure hope
they get to some of the actual claims here. Come on. >> You
love those. >> I love those big
nimble. Nimble.
>> It's not
>> Your girl looks like Randall from
>> That's Steve Bashmi's character.
>> Who I do look >> You look like Steve Bashmi. >> That's
not wrong. Okay. That's not wrong. That's not wrong. Is live
hate allowed here? Yeah, you can hate laugh. There's also laugh
love allowed here. Okay, live love love. >> You're [__]
mean. That is mean. >> What do I look like? >> I've
been told. Is that true?
>> You look like [__] You look like
>> You look fat and stupid and ugly. >> Right now
we're fighting. >> Like it is just like Yes. 100%.
>> There is something there.
>> there is something there. I was going to sub to your
only fans cuz I like your tits, but then you talk [__]
to my king. Are you Are you going to continue the hunt at all
cost? >> I'm going to wait till they get to about 48, then
fire up the app again and then I'll uh
I'll be catching up. >> Re, you're not getting it. >> I
still and the other I'm in this. >> She's having puppy.
She's having puppies. She's having puppy.
>> Guys, I started that rumor about myself. >> That's
not true. That's not true. That's not true. >> A rumor
I started about myself. She does lean into it though. >> What
did I miss? Can my dog get your wife's number? Yeah. >> Okay.
Surely they've got to get to something more substantial eventually,
>> Like that. >> Surely. Surely.
>> Surely they get to something more sus more substantial.
>> Than just talking to chat.
>> I love you so much, but you are in a constant state
of death. Though that's not the right. >> Hello everybody.
I can read chat now.
>> Come on, man. We're really not doing drama here. Someone
told me the address like the the cute text and the the wedding
comment about Kimmy. When do we get this? Oh, hold on. >> Got
thrown under the bus for what?
you mean the back again? >> No. Do you not understand the
historical >> No, I No, no, no. >> She tried to sit
in the front of the >> Baby 44.
>> I've seen that a lot lately. Nepotism. >> Smoking
in your car laugh. Really?
Loser parents. That would suck, >> dude. I have loser parents.
>> I know that sucks for you. >> No, I love it. My
dad is $200,000 in debt. Coolest guy I know. >> By a long
>> You're only You're not cool if you have like millions
of dollars saved up. That's gay. Ride the tiger. Let that ride.
You're only cool if your money's on the table as you speak. >> I'm
going to beat your husband up. >> Number one crack. Hell
of a name. >> Leeching off your Only Fans girlfriend. I'm
leeching off of him. I don't pay rent. Magnus Z. I'm going to
beat your husband off. >> What? They're so funny. You guys
are the funniest chatters. You know that, right? Like there's
no other community of retards. Like SSB people are kind of like
just brain dead. But CX chatters >> I'll never ever be
nice to you guys under like any circumstances. Just so you know,
if you're from that community and you expect somebody to be nice
to you, [__] off. >> Actually, some of the
funniest retards. >> Drinking and smoking is crazy. Guys,
I don't drink very often, so when I do, it's a little staggering.
We've actually made more off of ISIS's only fans promo than I
did on KP before the week. So, thank you. >> So, like actually,
>> thank you guys for all the free money. >> You
don't want to get more clothes
>> I hate having more clothes, >> dude. What's wrong
with you?
>> cuz they respect I so much and they really want to win.
>> Oh, hold on. Hold on. God damn it. I just skipped over.
This is them dropping some some names. My bad. It's a little
>> I'm just trying to get through this cuz like obviously
there's going to be some down points. >> We've actually
made more off of Ice's Only Fans promo than I did on >> Oh
no, I went back too far. >> Thank you. >> So like
actually >> I I'll speed it up. >> Thank you guys
for all the free money.
>> You don't want to get Mark? You want to watch her?
>> Godamn it. >> Guys, while getting Wool Haml call
Adriana and Chicken. Uh Adriana and Chicken actually cut us off.
Yeah, >> cuz they respect Ice Poseidon so much and they
really want to win. >> Yeah, let's go over the the bridges
that I've burned.
Hondro won't talk to me. >> Said, "Nah, Goon, that was
up, bro." Nick White said, "Goon, what the hell, dude? What's
wrong with you?" I can't do a chicken impression. Dan was like,
"Nah, man. That [__] ain't cool, bro. Like, Ice is
my boy, but Goon, you was my boy. Like, you had my back." But
like, nah, man. Then Gary was like, "I can't do a Gary impression."
>> Yeah. No. >> I'm glad I burned the Sand Pepper
bridge for Ice, though. You're welcome.
That's two victories. Sam Pepper.
>> I mean, Sam Pepper didn't seem to know either. Sam Pepper
knew Kimmy's version, which was not really known. >> Yeah,
but he still wanted to leak it to cause drama. >> Well,
I don't know if he wanted to leak. What he wanted to leak, I
think, was that was something that was not true. >> Yeah,
but he still want he still wanted to like add drama. I don't
think I think he just knew they I think he knew they [__]
and he thinks the letter makes him like look better. I'm sorry.
>> Life is related. >> It has to be it. >> From
what I understand.
>> In fact, isn't it better when you reference a letter
if you think it exists? Like, hey, I know about something embarrassing
you did. Why don't you leak everything, bro? Why don't you leak
that you were this girl and you were obsessed with her and like
you her though? Why don't you leak all >> Me and Kimmy
had like made out a few times and like almost hooked up. So,
Sam Pepper is still a scumbag. >> Okay. Okay, but what
does that mean? Is there are other people in ISIS's audience
who don't know that Sam Pepper is a scumbag? Is there anybody
on the internet who's heard of Sam Pepper who doesn't know he's
a scumbag? What does that even mean? You say, "Yeah, Sam Pepper's
still a scumbag." Yeah, you literally nothing about this could
have changed that. What? Huh? >> I can't wait till she
leaves you. She won't though. >> I can't. >> Like
I I can't get rid of this woman. >> Guys, did you see uh
Zeus streaming? You can you >> I'm a white man. Why? >> Okay,
hold on. Yeah, somebody does need to get me the Zeus clips, too.
They might be in the Discord. It's possible they're in the scavenger
hunt channel. I'll go look for them. I actually need to watch
the Zeus clips cuz what I've heard about the Zeus seems insane.
>> Aspirin and drink. >> We built the roads. Huh?
>> Why can't you take aspirin and drink? >> Things
your blood.
>> I'm a white man.
>> Yeah, Zeus might actually be Zeus actually made yesterday
not boring his [__] What do you think Zeus was suffering
from? Mania.
>> Oh, yeah. That was like classic 54. >> Is it wasn't
he like Army 54 or >> Oh, that's that.
>> What did they
>> So, hold on. Kickst IRL suffered a racist psychotic
episode when he found out that Shuy had pushed his girlfriend.
Zeus streamed himself driving his truck at 105 mph to Austin
in hopes of finding and likely murdering Shivy. Stream ended
when he got pulled over. >> You see how white boys drive.
You see how white boys drive. This is how we drive in America.
We're about to you the
up. One of our white queens. Flexy Fay may be a hoe to a lot
of y'all,
but y'all about to learn she ain't no hoe to me. She ain't no
hoe to nobody.
>> affir that I am not to be with
no matter the point. Okay. with you with flexi fay. You [__]
with me. You [__] with me. You [__] half
a Texas that Holy [__] That's that white boy.
That's that white boy. White people win.
Period. >> Is he just doing Is he just doing the Richard
Spencer rant? I win. You lose
>> I don't give a what you think. I I literally don't.
We win every time.
Oh, you're going to take our ships over in the Atlantic. The
Yemen, the [__] Houthies, you Houthies. Houthies
are going to win. No, Hassan
you. We win, [__] We win no matter
>> You think you are uh you know re Zeus is the reason
we have the rule that you're not allowed to be drunk in VC? I
did not know that. But uh sounds like it's just another case
of white dudes winning, I guess. Uh man enough
to with me.
Here's my goddamn license plate. Find me. >> Speed up.
>> Hey, we're on zero. We're on zero. >> I think
so. Somebody asked you, you're not allowed to be drunk in VC.
That's a rule. I think it's more like if you're obnoxiously drunk,
if you're like disgustingly drunk in VC, probably that's a rule.
>> See if we get See if we get We're literally going 100
105.
See if we can get to the thing. Maybe going as fast as we can
with zero miles.
See if we get the There's a love. There's a L. Are we going to
make it? We're going to make it. >> Use the right lane
to take exit 632 onto US 183. >> Oh my god, we made it.
>> Turn left straight into the park. >> White boy
summer. Yes.
You Mexican
dude.
Uh,
>> white boy summer.
>> Oh, he was out of I see. He was out of gas and he thought
he wasn't going to make it. That's funny. >> [__]
yeah. We win, baby. Shuy, you're about to get your goddamn ass.
I just want you to know. You're about to get your goddamn ass.
I'm going to prison.
I'm going to prison. They're getting [__] up. You
think Zeno is scary?
This is This is like Did we If only this guy was born like 10
years earlier, we could have had white white fuzzy. Okay. He's
probably too old to make it work. All right. But if this guy
was born 10 years earlier, we could have had white fuzzy for
sure. >> They're getting up.
>> Yes. This is the guy who got evicted. >> Scary.
You're about to learn.
So, please the white noise.
Let's pull over. White noise, dude. >> Okay. Sorry. All
right. I just needed the I need the reference point. Okay.
>> Oh, irritate stomach lining.
>> Well, I can't. >> No, like you always have stomach
when you drink. Why would you irritate it? >> No, not when
I have water. Just when I have to feel up. >> This is what
happens when the girl runs.
Girl ran over ice beside.
Like that is >> the thing about me is that I having a strong
woman means more because she will kneel if you deserve it. >> I
tamed the beast. I tamed the beep that just took down CX. >> Tim
is my master. I will literally get I will get on my knees and
kneel before him. I'm not going to do that to some like ice beside.
>> She just says all the most enraging things. I just know
all so many people are mad when she speaks and that was that's
what makes it funny to me. >> What a Chicken and Adriana
said to you. Chicken and Adriana said, "Look,
we think you guys are like super cool, but
we like really respect Ice Poseidon and we really want to win
this and we just can't, you know,
we're just going to let you guys go and do your own thing. Good
luck to you." And we said, "Good luck to you. If anyone deserves
to win, it's that." >> Yeah. We don't give a if people
cut us off after this. Like, that just proves our point. We'd
rather be right. We already won. If people need to cut us off,
then that's that's that. Do your thing. Everyone's got bills
to pay. We don't vote that against anybody. >> I'm not
drunk enough anymore. >> They probably don't have bills
to pay. They um they probably don't have like that much of a
problem to be honest with you. I just don't think so. >> This
lady has a big nose. Timmy, please give me the naming or surgeon.
I don't want to have to go all the way over. >> Dude, she
has 80k in the bank. Damn. >> Well, you're probably wondering
how it all got here. >> Won instead of goon.
Won. One of these two will cheat on the other in 2025. That would
be Guys, you're not gonna like what happens if one of us cheats
on the other. >> Yeah, I just saw what my wife >> Goon
could just do that part-time react stuff and he's be he he's
fine or be fine. He's good at that. >> Capable of on a
public stage. I think I'll avoid that at all cost. Like she she
did something so brutal over the internet at the slightest inconvenience
that for me to do something like that to her with the physical
proximity, I think I'd be cooked. I don't think life would be
worth living after that. >> Pretty woman, what's your ethnicity?
You look amazing. You want to tell him, >> Uh, she's Chinese.
>> Not Chinese.
>> Timmy doesn't like when I talk about my ethnicity because
I'm not white. >> Cuz he didn't build the road like Zeus
>> That's true. I look trans.
>> I look trans.
>> Okay. Gunnar is like a masculine dude, but like if you
just softened the features like a tiny bit, I could see just
like a super butch lesbian. The haircut, the mustache was like
a little more trimmed. Not quite as filled in. I think so. >> She
does actually look like she recently got ticked down. That's
that we have been having the past 48 hours >> in between
just watching clips and just react lording. We've been watching
Wednesday and having copious amounts of so good. I don't have
to [__] run around looking for scans. I don't have
to run around look for fa ass RFIDs. >> I feel like I'm
at a slant. >> You are. The road is tilted. >> The
white the whites did not build this road according to >> you
guys stink like he's pretty stinky right now. >> I smell
like I >> did Kimmy join. No, but she's open
>> I'm good on that. >> I'll teach her how to cook
and clean and she can look >> hop in the Discord. See if
anyone's going to hop in. Something is not right with Lab's finger
bones. >> Is the 200th body?
>> What's wrong with her fingering? >> Only fans
girls have high body count. The highest body count women I know
is women who don't talk about sex. >> What's wrong with
the finger bones? I don't see it.
>> I don't see it. What What do we got going on here? We
got something weird going on here. I don't see what's wrong with
the bones. No, I don't see it. Her fingers look okay. Uh, it's
the nurses
>> I guess that teachers
>> okay that possibly that was maybe the only comment I
could throw out but lab would kill me if I said that. So >> teachers
and flight Yeah. >> flight attendants >> nurses teachers
and flight attendants. >> I'd rather date like an actual
than either of the three of those. >> I just don't have
a very >> Who knows what those flight attendants are getting
up to? Just getting strange flying everywhere. I don't um >> something
happens when you're that close to the sun that much.
>> It's the air pressure. >> It's like the air pressure
makes you a >> It's the air pressure. >> Why people
that have frequent flyer miles I don't trust. >> I don't
let men who I don't respect have sex with me and I respect very
little men because I can out alpha
too many of I need a Spartan man. >> You going to ever
navigate or am I still keep looking over? >> I don't I'm
drunk and I'm Oh no. >> Miss the turn.
>> Sorry. Yeah. I'm sorry. Don't hit me. the [__]
>> I actually I actually went viral for not being destroyed
on theion.
Destiny is an alpha. I would never Destiny in a million years
in a million years. In a >> You got destroyed on the whatever
podcast. No, she did. She literally actually just embarrassed
the [__]
>> Just to be clear, like just so you guys know, I know
you guys might have more knowledge than apparently Destiny, but
he doesn't claim he laugh either. I'm Yeah, I uh Destiny went
down on her. That's the only interaction they had as far as I
know. They've literally they've literally discussed that on my
stream. >> Well, I actually went viral for not being destroyed
on the >> That's what you do. You go into it. >> Is
a [__] Not now. No, it's not. You call that hooking
up. You call it a [__] You call it giving me head.
You call it anything that doesn't make you think that you somebody
>> new community and you just rain hell upon them. >> At
the first sign of weakness, you will press the button. >> Do
not give this woman the nuclear code. She would do terrible things.
>> No, I would be a really bad president. Can me roleplay
on the next Only Fans video? Yes, I will be putting on a blonde
wig and all proceeds will be going to keeping Kimmy out of the
women's shelter. Whatever. Pot is so boring. Didn't want. Yeah.
Transracial only fans were serial
right there. >> Well, I try to say that. >> Why does
Lav hate Kimmy? It's a mix of Kimmy having been with Goar and
that what do you call it? that uh it's a mix of like her insecurity
from Kimmy being with Gunnar,
but also apparently Kimmy was rude to her at some point. I don't
>> Couldn't even say it once.
>> that's a good thing.
>> First of all, those aren't dogs. That's That was a dolphin.
That was the famous bad dragon dolphin.
>> And yeah, I was curious about it.
I have a lot of respect for dolphins. >> Failed singer.
30 million on Spotify. Call that a fail.
>> Shouted out by Billy Isish. You call that failing? >> I
didn't like singing very much. I like writing more than I like
singing.
>> That's some code, but whatever. It's >> Kimmy
lying in her Discord about what >> she has to like there's
nothing. >> She's she's having access to her [__]
>> bank account. She's doing it. >> Also, real quick,
somebody did send me the uh the cute bot clip. I think >> Junior
was going to pick up Kimmy from the airport, but but I I didn't
like that or something because cuz he knew. And then they got
into
>> Oh [__]
>> Oh, we watched this last night. Oh, why didn't I realize
what this was last night? I I got the Nick White part. Damn.
I remember I went to a park. >> Jesus. Okay. All right.
Damn. Where am I? I'm here. >> Everything she can. >> Yeah.
Let them do their thing, guys. Let them save at least a little
face. We already said our piece. We don't give a [__]
It's already over. >> It's a joke to us at this point cuz
it's just it's out there.
>> Can Can you guys stop talking about her breast implants?
Jesus Christ. >> You guys can run with it. Have fun with
>> Nothing likable about you. Sorry. >> Did you guys
see Kimmy saying her and Paul are going to stay together? with
>> they should. >> No, I >> just run it back,
man. Sure, it'll go >> This is the thing is like obviously
what comedian did is really yucky, but I think I think wasting
a woman's time for 10 years like >> there's something wrong
about that. You guys need to be chill. Okay,
>> it's very evil. So,
>> we're kind of on Kimmy's side. a 10 long year humiliation
ritual
of not >> and she's message and let's be very clear he
has not been
>> guys I just noticed we have 20 minutes left on the stream
we are three subs away from another hour sorry two more hours
in the stream get the subs in three subs away if we don't make
this um I'm probably just going to peace out for the night but
>> messaged her friends and >> more content still
got the xen stuff >> all those [__] >> need
those subs need to get them are not.
Everyone has their issues. Their issues are on a another scale.
>> I just don't know why >> we have our issues. I
was just in the psych war. >> Yeah. But we own up to them.
Like we're not playing this little like don't tell
>> It's just [__] weird. Like if you're going
to be public, be public and do your thing.
>> No shame in having your life. >> Every couple
has their issues. She by putting him in a position like that
though by not telling him.
>> What is that? What is that? What is that? Come on, dip.
Thank for the gifted sub. Let's go. >> And then like having
him. >> JTO holding the stream hostage.
This is the monetization scheme every night for the past like
>> What do you mean holding it hostage?
>> Uh, Mew Crusty, thank you for the gifted sub. We're
easily going to make this, by the way. But also,
>> XTRay, thank you for the sub announcement. Thank you.
Thank you. >> Uh, I I don't stop segments midway just cuz
we run out of time. I'd always finish the segment, but with the
guy that like had to drive her home in his car because she was
too drunk. Like
>> Not good. >> That was like the first night that
was at uh that was at that hot tub stream. I remember that. It
was at the hot tub stream. She had me drive her home in his car.
That was before anything even
>> Why would she tell him? because they were together and
it was >> Oh, and after the Hunger Games, like I drove
one of the U-Hauls home, these U-Hauls, man. I drove one of the
U-Hauls home and like with all the paintball guns and [__]
loaded in it. I got pulled over, by the way. But I told the cop
like, "Yeah, I was doing a YouTuber."
>> Let's go. Thank you, Anonymous, for the gifted sub.
That's all the subs, guys. We got everything. There it is. Let's
go. Two more hours in the stream.
38. Boom. Bam. Awesome. After that, I dropped it off at the U-Haul
rented rental rental place or wherever or at Ice's house. And
then Kimmy drove me to my hotel
or no, she drove me to Dunc's Airbnb.
And then I asked her, I was like, "Hey, is everything cool?"
Like, he didn't care about me being in the Hunger Games or anything.
She's like, "No, it's just content. Like, he doesn't he doesn't
care about that stuff." Holy.
>> So, dude,
I don't think she's evil. I think she's just I don't even think
she's evil. The more we look at it, it's I just think she's really
stupid.
>> I don't even think she was trying to do it on purpose,
honestly. If she was, then she's genuinely evil. But I think
she's just stupid. Kimmyy's actually evil. You should see her
messages about you guys. I saw >> I always care about Lav's
appraisal of who's evil. Don't we all? like the her long message
about >> yeah that was her old >> I forgot what she
even said uh about how I cheated on my husband and my first husband
and >> anonymous just tipped $3. Do you think Ice knew
what's up between you and Kimmy and decided to blow up your >> Hey,
Stinkfist. What's up, buddy? Haven't seen you in a while. How's
it >> Sip and is still dating Kimmy on the low. And is
content farming? >> No, I don't I don't think it's content
anymore. Like it's >> No. No, he's definitely. But yeah,
do you see? She called me insecure and then was like and and
Tim's mom even asked about me at their wedding. >> Oh,
here we go. >> Girl, what
what are you saying?
Like, what are you >> Yeah, my mom asked like, "Oh, I thought
Kimmy lived with you guys." Like, my mom didn't know that me
and Kimmy were hooking up. That's how little of a thing it was.
What?
>> And girl, people like you because you're People like
you because they think you're sweet. They're like, "Oh, where's
this where's the sweet dumb girl?
>> Laugh's so mean. Why you got to be so mean? I could
just be nice." >> Like there's there's no Yes, you are
likable and you should have been at our wedding. We would have
loved to have you >> Yeah, there would have been no problem.
>> There would have been no problems if you were at our
wedding. >> So mean for no reason. >> Oh my god,
guys. I did it. There was no no dog. We don't even have I've
never even met a dog. >> I'm never going to dogs on stream
again. >> Evil Jew. Okay.
That was so refreshing.
Yeah, Matt, we went so long without any anti-semitism on a stream.
That was crazy. That just caught me totally off guard. >> Oh,
you wouldn't believe the amount of people that have reached out
to us behind the scenes saying, "Oh my god, thank god somebody
finally said this about
the wave of people." >> The amount of messages I got from
other women saying,
"Finally, someone
>> refreshing." Yeah, it just it shooks it shook things
up. It shook things up.
me down or like said something about >> we still aren't
racist. Okay, so everything's fine. >> So many messages
>> again. I
I feel like saying this is either it's like just to [__]
with Kimmy again, right? I feel like all of this is just to [__]
with Kimmy again. Oh, we got so many messages just saying thank
you for explaining that Kimmy's such a [__] People
don't realize she's such a Okay, thank you so much. We got dozens
of messages, hundreds of messages from people just all saying
that Kimmy's a total. Okay.
Um
I again not unlike when Kimmy was saying some about them, right?
I'm just like I would need some proof of this, you know? I need
some some proof something. Anything >> like it just it
it literally vindicates everything we've said. There are so many
people that are tired of living under >> super slander
if I is lying. >> We're not gay. >> First of all,
I'm not gay and also I perpetuated that lie for money. Like I
I started that rumor about myself. We don't do the whole thing.
>> I I suppose I didn't think he's doing something like
she [__] a dog, but I I made up that rumor about
myself to to make money. I'm >> This is the This is another
problem Lav has, right? She can lean into jokes halfway. And
then eventually once people start saying the joke over and over
again, she gets annoyed. You shouldn't lean into the joke if
you're going to get annoyed, right? That's it's tough. It probably
happens to most people lean into some joke, right? But she like
leans into the dog thing and then it starts to like actually
annoy her and then she like backs off. Right. >> I'm a
troll online. Online for 10 years. >> So is he now the
shoes on the other foot like what? >> Yeah. I I there's
no You can't hurt me with something I made up about my There's
really bad traffic.
>> that's okay. >> Well, I I hesitate scrotum. I
hesitate to say okay who actually like irritated I don't think
Destiny really with lab that badly to tell you the truth. I think
there's a different community that [__] with Lav,
but they already get a pretty rough ride in terms of reputation
around here. Okay. But I think there's a different there's a
different community that probably would laugh way way way
more than Destiny ever did. Okay.
Kind of.
Yeah. I keep going. >> Okay. The slander case here might
be [__] Yeah. >> Yeah. We don't care about
slander or any like that. Like >> we make we make enough
money on my only fans that keeps us afloat. To be fair, she went
after the platform of the person. So, you go after somebody's
platform, they might go buck wild on you. Okay, >> Rez,
I cannot wait for the edit that you >> dude. It's going
to be an hour long. It's going to be an hour long. >> I
feel like there's no way this Mark Carney fellow
I I feel like you're not you're not Chinese Asian, are you? You're
not the same person, are you? That would be crazy to me. There's
like another person who would come in here occasionally and they're
a massive Lav fan, but I don't know who that is. Okay. Okay.
Okay. >> Why did you cry about not being able to pay for
the >> sound event? Okay. >> Um because we wanted
you guys to pay for >> Yeah. Sorry. Sorry I lied to you
guys. >> No, it's obviously like I mean we're not strapped
for cash, but we obviously wanted the trip to pay for itself.
>> Yeah, it's just logical. We want the trip to pay for
itself and now uh it paid for itself a few days ago. >> Scam
day three. I think everything is covered. But >> now with
the $1 KP and all this other man, guys, it's really rough. Gift
subs. >> And also, I've got >> You realize Goon wouldn't
be with you if Kimmy didn't leave him. >> You were left.
I had to nurse. You don't know. You don't know how sad Tim was
after Kimmy left him. >> Kger, thank you for the sub. Thank
you. Thank you. >> I had to nurse him back to hell.
>> I had to nurse him back to hell.
>> Orbiting laugh, by the way.
Well, we're definitely going to make money on the trip because
I have to go pick up the check from Miz Kit for the take down
>> auto probably. Yes, >> I will be pay now. I' I've
made my uh made my mark. Back to Twitch, guys. They're going
to hit me with the view >> with the mis. >> Yeah,
extra Emily collab has been booked. Like, I'm I'm moving up in
the world. Done with this whole kick.
Dan Clant is giving going to give me the medal of freedom. >> Was
he like an abandoned puppy? He was so sad. He'd cry every day.
Okay.
Letter to her crying. >> How do you cry in a letter? >> This
letter still hasn't been produced, right? As far as I know, I've
not seen any copies of the letter. I've not seen anything about
the letter. Seems to be in the letter. Where's the letter? >> And
the only reason I texted her a few months ago after the nose
job was like >> it was nice to text. >> Yeah. I was
on stream and I you guys came in my chat and we're like, >> "Hey,
are you gonna like are you gonna reach out to your friend, your
pal Kimmy?" And I was like, >> it was nice to text her.
She was obviously going through a hard time. >> Yeah. We
wouldn't wish. We don't want her to be sad. No. >> We don't
want her to kiss herself. Yeah. >> Well, now.
>> Like, wait, what? Uhhuh. Huh? What did you No, not now.
No, not not ever. Not. I was like, well,
well, now. >> Talk to your friend, your pal Kimmy. And
I like >> it was nice to text her. She was obviously going
through a hard time. >> Yeah. We wouldn't wish. We don't
want her to be sad. >> We don't want her to kill herself.
Well,
>> Just kidding. >> But no, I
Just kidding. >> She obviously I It would really suck.
>> Yeah, it would suck so bad to like mutilate yourself
and like be be really regretful about it.
>> How many lies does goon have to tell his mom about you?
We lived with them for 6 months before he started leeching off
of me and my only fans. We were leeching off of his parents.
>> I'm King Leech, baby. I just moved from town to town
leeching. >> Well, I've exposed Alys Alexis Deello. Who's
Alexis Dell? Is that Alexis? The >> Alexis is
>> So, the weird thing is is like Ice is apparently talking.
Apparently, it's well known that Gunnar's got a bit of a gambling
problem. Okay, I do think Ice kind of underestimates that, especially
if they've had fights about this, the kind of pressure he's putting
on them or the kind of he's talking when he drops like these
steak chests. So, so I assume these are chests that give you
money to gamble on stake.com, right? I kind of feel like uh just
in terms of like this whole thing, I'm like thinking back on
that, it seems a little seems a little crazy to me that you would
say, "Oh, that's just banter." I don't know. >> She doesn't
do any I don't think she's done a single thing wrong in her life.
>> Normal. She's a good singer. >> Is she? >> Yeah.
I saw her sing.
>> I saw her singing on stream the other uh other day.
There was like >> literally the week before the event,
there was a crash out stream where she leaked. He gambled all
their money and she was in a mental home or something. Wait,
where's this? They stream this. They didn't stream this. Shut
up. >> Goon Sputin >> on Goon's channel or on her
channel? >> She's friends with Kimmy. She's going to need
friends right now. >> Yeah, we're not trying to ruin all
her like personal friendships and we don't care. But there's
other streamers that are not friends with her that reached out
to us and said like, "You guys are totally right. Vindicated,
blah blah blah. It's about time. It's been past due for a long
time that somebody just >> I do feel ma bad for um involving
Maddie because I think she got scared. >> Yeah, I think
she definitely got scared.
>> But I >> but I mean that like >> she did
do that. >> Anonymous just tipped $3.
Ice is still dating Kimmy. He just wanted to sip when you clown
him on stream. This is literally for content. Yeah, we do feel
bad that Maddie had to like >> she didn't have to, but
she did delete her stream and all that. But it's up that Kimmy
torched her career months ago because she was intimidated by
her because she was >> Yeah. And also you told me she told
you that while you guys were
>> She told you that she was >> She was actively
trying to get back with Paul. She was actively trying to get
back with Paul while you guys were and she was saying how she
was trying to Maddie and keep him away from Paul. >> I
don't think Maddie came around at that time. Maddie was later.
I think Maddie showed up like after
she like started streaming after.
>> Um we had already moved to LA >> and then Kimmy
got really but hurt and
>> Yeah. So the timeline there, >> I don't quite
remember the whole timeline, but it's weird. But she did like
tank this girl's career because she was threatened by her. Anybody
Anybody with eyes can see like Oh, uh Maddie or Kimmy, which
one?
I'm I'm just saying like that was >> Kimmy even did it.
That's why Kimmy did >> Maddie is very very beautiful and
she's very sweet. If you like blonde girls,
>> uh I don't know, dude. Maybe I'm just totally reading
into it, but when life goes, if you like blonde girls, it's like
if you're
then Mattie is very cool. Matty would be >> I've gotten
no concrete evidence that they dated at all. Moody Morgan. They
seem to be hooking up while living in the same house. >> Zena
facing possibly 10 years. Holy [__]
I've heard that earlier. That's so >> There's no way. >> It
It will It'll get reduced a little bit, but I heard it was the
governor's daughter's friend that got hit with a
>> Is that true? Apparently apparently there's some issues
with Zena. Okay. >> That could just be rumor, though. >> Yeah,
that'd be not good. You two have great heart being right and
ruining it. I couldn't read that
>> did not know. >> We don't know who knew. Like
that's the thing. There's so many lies blown up by Timmy that
we don't know who knew. >> We know. We Your roommates knew.
>> Yeah. After though like a year after. >> Yeah.
But >> and then >> and Sam said that he knew, >> but
he didn't know actually.
>> But no, like if a girl knows. >> Dude, what the
I just went to just chatting on kick and there's like so many
Spanish streamers there. Holy [__] What the hell?
Like so many. >> That means all her girlfriends are going
to find out within the social circle. So people knew behind the
scenes
like tons of people >> problem. No, no, no problem. >> Please
move in with Let's have a
>> I'm saying there's a lot of Spanish
>> I'm just saying that's all. Just I'm just saying is
all >> lots of people came forward and said they knew for
a while. I mean >> a lot of chatter kind of upset. >> Yeah,
you guys you guys me you guys collap collap.
Also, you did a lot of those collapsed to make me upset. I was
previously I was married at the time and I kept telling him I
was not going to I was not going to fly out. I was not going
to fly out. I'm not going to >> I would not say there's
something of a white genocide on kick. I'm This starting to drag.
So, we're about to move on. Okay. Starting to drag. I don't know.
I don't know how much more we got here. Keep watching for a little
bit. But You're a sweet talker. >> Get some coffee tonight.
>> You sleep on You sleep on the floor. You have a pile
of trash in your room. I'm not going to fly out to meet you.
I'm married and here we are. >> Now look at us. Can't get
rid of you. >> Did Kimmy really need the surgery? Nobody
needs surgery. >> No, they she absolutely didn't. Like
she's ruled by her insecurities. That's >> Nobody needs
that. >> She's ruled by insecurities and deceit. Like it's
not there's no logical explanation for any of the that she >> She
didn't need a nose job. >> Yeah. Not at all. >> She
really need that
>> that laboplasty. She really need that. >> This
is like the the most evil surgery by like a million miles. Like
it's just an evil evil evil surgery. >> Yeah. If you got
some wings on the bat,
>> There's nothing wrong with that. There's nothing wrong
with having wings. That's >> Oh, I see the um the governor
connection. I wonder if that's true. I wonder if you could figure
that out somehow.
Does anybody have any more info on that? the person that Zena
cuz that seems like that would be really weird. I can't see that
being true. Like the friend of the It's like the was it the friend
of the daughter of the governor that even if it was the daughter
of the governor. I don't know. It's un it's believable her telling
her girlfriend about it and then her friends uh her friend telling
her father about it about how awful it was how her friend was.
Dude, come on man. It's like a paintball.
Okay. 10 years for a paintball. That that's like a fine in community
service, bro. I don't even think she did. Like I don't remember
>> vividly, but she did not. >> She was fine. Like
there was nothing to be like scared of. >> There's a It's
never that bad. It's never that bad. >> They're lying about
her charges, too. They're showing the charges for that are for
negligent discharge of a firearm. And a paintball gun is not
a firearm in any state. Okay. >> If you're coming out like
this much,
>> Yeah. If it's flapping with the windows rolled out,
then maybe maybe step in and do something. But until then, >> at
that point, to live a better life, maybe. But >> remember,
Zena has prior. Okay.
If she prior to this murdered somebody in cold blood and someone
with a paintball, I would still say, "Yeah, I don't think that's
10 years, bro. I don't think that's [__] 10 years.
That's crazy. That's wild." Okay. Yeah. Just the 10 years is
insane. But I do think I keep seeing the thing is for like a
assault with a firearm or dischar reckless discharge of a firearm
or something. I don't know. >> It's like a nose job. You
should only get a nose job if you can smoke a cigarette in the
rain. >> Confirmed lab has a vat.
>> No, I have I think my vagina is perfect. I love I would
never touch my vagina. >> I'll touch it.
>> Anonymous just tipped $3. What is the logic of competing
in his competitions where cash prizes are involved while keeping
this information from ISIS? Nice
>> dude. Hey, guy who's like paying my money and is my
only cloud connection to the space. Uh, I your girlfriend. That
girlfriend you're about to propose to. Yeah, I totally up, bro.
Just figure you should know. I did a wink there with that. I
don't know if you guys could see it. Well, you can't see it,
but I hope you could hear it and you visualize it now. I did
a little wink there. >> The logic of competing is I thought
that he was aware. >> Anonymous just tipped $3 again. Now
that you're finished in the kick community, just come clean about
all the e girls Kiana Gizlane Maxwell provided for you. Start
with wild Latina.
>> Like I would listen is a she
how is that even starting to answer the question? Yeah, Lav has
the right expression. How is that even starting to answer the
question? How in the you supposed to start there? He's going
to say something like Keano is going after all these girls, but
that's insane. Listen, Kiana's a Okay, shut up. >> Okay,
so Kiana [__] a bunch of these girls. Is that what
you're saying? >> You're [__] No, that like
I would Listen, Kiana is a bisexual. >> The [__]
>> She actually would take women from me. It pissed me
off. That bugged. >> I don't want to hear this. You [__]
>> She was bisexual and I would like What are the girls
going to do? The big fat caveman that lives in the second story
or the tiny Filipino Asian woman with 5,000 average? Like, [__]
her. Ew.
>> Lav hates her, too. Does Lav hate Lav? Well, I mean,
they probably hate each other. I'm sure a lot of these women
just hate each other. Okay. Women don't get along with women.
That's just facts. Okay. All women hate all of the women. That's
just the law of the jungle. Okay. I didn't make the rules. >> Wifey
says, "No thanks." Yeah. I don't want to hear about how he was
you like running through as many women as possible or speedrun.
Don't want to hear about it. Thank you. >> We were just
chatting. >> You're so stupid.
Next thing, next thing you know. Okay.
Hey, Jaw. I hope you know that Gonar Kiana. Okay. Go you bot.
Jaw. Just so you know. Just so you know. Jaw, >> you're
actually so annoying. You're actually so annoying. >> Tell
me that wasn't good. >> Tell me that wasn't a good one.
>> No, it wasn't. It wasn't. And you're >> I love
you. >> He was running through minors. That's
>> Shut up. >> No. I just wonder if she's going to
say >> He might say something. >> He tried. I saw
that she was trying to talk about >> hearing up like the
like falls to it longer or something. >> Yeah, I think
so. >> Yeah, I can see it. She'll swing for the fence and
she has to. >> Wait, who are they talking about now? They're
not talking about Kiana. They talk about now. Wait, did I miss
did I miss somebody in the chat that they talked about? What
the What the What the But it's completely negated by the fact
that she wanted to move back in. Like if >> No, they're
talking about Kimmy. They're talking about Kimmy. They're talking
about Kimmy.
They're talking about Kimmy. It makes no sense to be talking
about Kiata or else they'd be leaking that uh Gooner, which I
don't think they have a Predator. Then why' you want to live
with a Predator? Seems a little bit off. >> For your thick,
I was Ivy Ren.
You're so >> Wait, no. Did Gunnar hit did go Ivy Ren too
before our boy? No. >> You're so annoying. Wait, you're
a bread now? Yeah. She's one ugly looking girl you married. I
don't think the chat >> I can't even I can't even remember
the guy's name now. Not Not Oh, not Tim. Where? The Ivy Ren girl
who did the the the date with the Terry. God damn it. Why can't
Terry? How do I always forget Terry? He he occupies so much of
my mental landscape and I can never remember his name. God, that
was the most Kino stream. >> Baby, I think you're very
beautiful. >> You think I'm pretty? >> I think you
very pretty. You're so beautiful with the perfect beard balance.
And let's just say that um maybe just maybe you might have the
perfect little the perfect boob. >> Also, that also doesn't
make her look >> Sorry, I should have I should have paused
that before and and skip past it. I apologize for letting you
hear that. I can tell that I didn't want to hear that. I didn't
pause it soon enough to skip by. >> She's like, "Yeah,
she was just him and they weren't." >> Oh, thank God. >> How
thick is his rod?
>> Wait, did I try to say that my wife was option two?
>> Yeah. So what what they're failing to understand and
this might >> also that also doesn't make her look better
if she's like yeah she was just him and they weren't in a relationship
or trying to have one that doesn't make her look like less of
a like >> yeah but it was a it was 3 years ago
I was married >> I had a girlfriend back home >> that's
also true >> yeah I I literally had a girlfriend back >> oh
so he's an >> I was Kimmy while I was like visiting Texas
staying at the house like that that's just what it is. Like it
wasn't a real relationship with me and Kimmy at
>> Lav Lav is like picking, right? She's like hoping Ice
will watch this and hoping that if she says these things, it's
like she's still a Ice. She's still a Ice. Just say no. She's
like still a >> turned a hoe into a housewife. >> Sorry.
I didn't mean to be a I can take it all back. I would. >> No,
I'm I'm glad that you didn't. I'm glad that you learned things.
I think that you had to go through what didn't work before
you learned what worked. That's life. >> Wait, I just looked
at Zena's. It is not at all what you guys said it was. What the
Hold on. Hold on. These are Zena's charges. Just really quickly.
So, it's deadly conduct misdemeanor class A. Okay. $2,000 bond.
Assault causes bodily injury, misdemeanor, class A, $4,000 bond.
And then out of misdemeanor, undetermined misdemeanor. Hold for
another agency. 100,000. They're literally saying she has some
other warrant somewhere. How is this How is this 10 years for
one of these? How would one of these be 10 years? That's for
assaulting merc and nerd ballers. That would have been out of
Travis County. Deadly conduct is max 10 years. Okay, but would
they put a $2,000 bond on that if you were likely to get the
max sentence on that? Deadly conduct.
Hold on. Texas deadly
conduct
charge. Where the [__] did this song come from? What
the [__] Texas Penal Code deadly conduct current
as of January 1st, 2024. A person commits an offense if he recklessly
endangers or he recklessly engages in conduct that places another
person in a minute danger of serious bodily injury. Person commits
an offense if he knowingly discharges a firearm at or in the
direction of one or more individuals. A habitation, bro. No.
Knowingly discharges a firearm.
What? There's no you can get the max when it's for all firearms.
No. No. She's not at all. This is so stupid. If it's max 10 years,
that'd be like firing a like a rifle into a group of people.
That would be what you get 10 years to or for, right? Obviously,
she's not getting 10 years on this if she fired a paintball gun.
I was told it's not a firearm. So, I'll look it up in the background
while we watch this. >> Thing about chaos, it's >> When's
the Ivy Ren drop coming? Ivy Ren. I would have invited her
to be a sister wife if she didn't get picked on in a >> Yeah,
she seems cool. Well, she is cool,
>> she seems fun. She has a personality. >> She has
a great person.
>> she's very fun. She's just >> I don't know. >> She
lets people pee on her. >> Like when I was younger, I thought
that I would be like a full savant with like
Mormon five wives and just the the
woman tamer of the world. But I can barely handle one. Like I'm
fighting tooth and nail. I'm fighting tooth and nail to keep
you under bucket under the spell. I'm under the >> I'm
I'm like I'm at 10% HP. I'm in exit range right now. >> Sorry.
Uh,
can you find an in I just put this in chat GPT. Okay, I just
put this in chat GPT. Can you find an instance of someone being
charged with deadly conduct in Texas for firing a paintball gun
at a group of people? Yes, there indeed is an instance in Texas
where someone was charged with deadly conduct for firing a paintball
gun at a group of people. What happened? On August 9th, 2025,
a live streamer scavenger hunt took place. This is giving me
Zena.
It literally says Zena the witch.
No something else though. Me.
God damn it. >> She doesn't participate in dog activity.
You wouldn't get along. You still call yourself a feminist? I'm
not a liberal feminist.
But I would I would call myself a conservative. >> Oh,
am I misreading this? Apparently, under these two subsections,
you can get different So, this is a different subsection here.
For each of these, apparently, there are different charging guidelines.
So, she won't be found guilty of this, which would be the heavier
charges. Okay. This is a felony.
This
danger of seriously b serious bodily injury. This will be the
class A misdemeanor.
To be charged with the other class A misdemeanor, I assume. I
see. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Got >> No, I would call
myself an elitist feminist. Pink cloud. Married a cheater.
>> Listen, glass houses. I thought you hated Trump. I do
not like >> up to one year in jail for um for a class A
misdemeanor. Seems unlikely that she get she's not going to get
more than a year in jail. It might be unlikely that she gets
jail time to be honest with you. Yeah, Zena's got a felony already,
but I think it's I think it's like felony fraud, right? >> Going
to we'll getine. We're going to look at
that ruined
hunt.
Don't tell Paul. Don't tell him. Paul
doesn't know.
>> Thank you for the gift.
>> Dude, there could be such good lyrics rewritten for
this to make it apply way better. Polly doesn't know
>> what. Uh,
okay. Note to self take a road trip with this person. >> What
the
Ice Poseidon's career
prior to being packed up
>> his career is fine.
>> No, his career is fine, but no one's ever going to stop
talking about this.
>> Ice besides career is not going to take a dent from
this. He's at 10K right now, dude. People will probably watch
him more now that they can now they have something they can throw
in his face. It'll probably just help. >> They're staying
together. Like, no one's ever going to >> If they stay
together, he's a [__] >> No, there's like there's
no way.
>> What did she do? I still haven't I still haven't heard
somebody articulate what she did.
>> I feel like I should have this person on stream. I feel
like I should try to find a way to get in touch with Kimmy and
be like, "Hey, should you come and talk to me?" Cuz like I need
to know
what the happened here that both parties seem to think you did
wrong. I can't see any evidence that you've done something
Didn't she lie to both parties? Someone says she didn't she didn't
talk about the extent, but what did she say
That's what I need to know, right? I don't know what she said
exactly. So, what did she lie about? Did she say Did Paul say
I want to know everything? And what did he ask? Cuz if he said,
"Can you just tell me like the basics?" Well, we kind of hooked
up. Like, okay, that's one thing. If he said, "Tell me everything.
Tell me exactly what happened." And she kept things from him,
right? But she answered in a way that made him made him think
like he's okay. He knows everything now. That would be
>> Thank you, Biscuit, for the 100 gifted sub. Thank you.
bar. Why didn't you marry June? >> Didn't Trump get married?
>> Yeah, this Yeah, this literally Trump
>> Trump's kids. Yeah. >> Didn't Trump kids marry
the Jewish >> Uh, yeah.
>> Trump's literally number one [__] What What
kind of question was that? Israel's best [__] We
can we not can we not with this garbage? Okay. >> The world
go look at it. >> I I'd kind of hope there'd be like some
novel stuff here. This really seems like there's nothing novel.
That's too bad. This could have been if Kimmy had gone live,
maybe we could have had a little more stuff going on here, but
it seems like in the end, this is about as far as it goes. Okay,
it's about as far as this drama goes. I don't know if we can
get anything more out of it. Seems like it's just about wrapped.
Unless we had ice statements throughout the day, possibly.
Get anything from Ice Boseidon today?
How's he looking, bro? He looks he looks rough. Even now he looks
really rough.
Jesus Christ. >> God, I Dude, I hate this. >> I looked
over there.
>> I look around here, but there's some people singing
and dancing and whatever.
>> Yeah, when I went to go place all the stickers at the
stations, it was at like 3:00 in the morning. And uh >> you
got some new clips today. >> So many crackhead hits every
every
Oh, sorry. Let me turn that up.
>> Turn that up for a sec. >> Like they were just
harassing me every station I went to. [__] million
>> Let's see. Let's see what we got here for clips today.
>> The Austin Fox News reported on on Zena and and everything.
And they said she's facing like 10 years in prison.
>> And a 10,000. >> That is based on that news site
misreporting that it was for firing discharging a firearm. That's
not what >> Dollar fine. So, I don't know. She She'll probably
get at least I mean at least a year or two in prison. I don't
know. I'm sure that So, I mean that
>> it could be that was 40. It was so It was near a
>> Okay. Well, it doesn't look like he addressed it anymore
today. So, he just moved on. Moved on. It's over. There's nothing
else here. It's all over and done with, guys. That's it.